erwartet uns heute im deutschen
bundestag
alfred schier tag 3 der haushaltswoche
heute und es geht unter anderem um die
etats für die ministerien wirtschaft und
klimaschutz es geht um ernährung und
landwirtschaft und um das thema
gesundheit also drei themen die zu den
großen themen in diesen tagen zählen und
zu den großen herausforderungen beginnen
wird aber die heutige der heutige tag
der haushaltswoche mit dem etat des
bundesinnenministeriums das hätte vor
drei vier fünf jahren noch ganz anders
im fokus und im mittelpunkt gestanden
und das aus nachvollziehbaren gründen
denn heute auf den tag genau vor drei
jahren ist der kasseler
regierungspräsident walter lübcke
erschossen worden von einem täter mit
inzwischen auch verurteilt und deshalb
kann man es auch so sagen
rechtsextremen völkischen nationalen
motiven das ganze und insgesamt muss man
sagen hat sich die lage in diesem feld
im bereich der politisch motivierten
straftaten
nicht verbessert im gegenteil im
vergangenen jahr war die anzahl solcher
straftaten so hoch wie nie auch die
anzahl der gewalttaten ist deutlich nach
oben gegangen und
rechtsextremistisch motivierte taten
ebenso wie judenfeindliche also
insgesamt keine besonders gute
ausgangslage aber im mittelpunkt in
diesen tagen bestehen vor allem andere
bereiche nämlich die digitale welt mit
chat und messenger diensten und deren
möglichkeiten mit ihren möglichkeiten ja
auch verbreitung verabredung zu
straftaten getroffen werden können also
wie dieses auch besonders intensiv
diskutiert es geht darum cyber aber auch
in pädokriminalität und manches mehr
also großes feld insgesamt wir wollen
ein paar punkte vorab aufnehmen schon
mal in unserem gespräch hier heute
morgen nach der wende bevor um neuen der
bundestag darüber diskutiert mit joana
gotha aus der fdp-fraktion wo sie
digital politische sprecherin erst guten
morgen grund der krise ist bei uns der
stellvertretende vorsitzende der spd
fraktion auch ihnen einen guten morgen
ich habe ziemlich viele themen
angerissen wir werden nur einen teil
davon erörtern können vielleicht aber
trotzdem erst mal allgemein täuscht der
eindruck oder ist diese koalition oder
ist auch dieses innenministerium bislang
von noch einiges schuldig geblieben im
vergleich zu dem was angekündigt worden
ist zu beginn der regierungszeit nein
ganz im gegenteil gerade der heutige
haushalt die mir für das
bundesinnenministerium beschließen ist
der höchste italien
bundesinnenministerium jemals in der
geschichte gehabt hat wir stärken die
bereiche cybersicherheit wir stärken die
bereiche bevölkerungsschutz und
katastrophenschutz wo wir die lehren
ziehen wollen gerade aus der schlimmen
flutkatastrophe im aartal zuletzt die
tornados die wir gesehen haben in
lippstadt und paderborn wo wir einfach
die großen bedrohungsszenarien auch
aufgrund der klimatischen veränderungen
letztendlich sehen aber auch die klaren
prioritäten im kampf gegen extremismus
insbesondere den rechtsextremismus sehen
der wie alle lage-einschätzung momentan
deutlich machen eine der größten
gefahren für die demokratie in unserem
land ist konkret ist noch nichts
verabschiedet
es ist verabschiedet dass wir gegen hass
und hetze verstärkt vorgehen wollen
gerade auch im internet wir haben ja wie
sie es ja auch angekündigt haben leider
fälle wo aus worten taten geworden sind
hier gehen wir ganz klar vor wir wollen
auch gleichzeitig im kampf gegen
extremismus dafür sorgen dass
verfassungsfeinde nicht im öffentlichen
dienst sind und wir wollen die mittel
für die demokratie um die demokratie zu
stärken auch mit einem demokratie
fördergesetz zeitnah auf den weg bringen
das sind schritte die gehen in die
richtige richtung um unsere demokratie
in unserem land zu stellen viele
vorhaben frau kutcher sind ihre sicht
der dinge na ja es wurde viel
angekündigt bis jetzt noch gar nicht
umgesetzt feser ist eigentlich damit
aufgefallen dass sie eher vorschläge
gemacht haben die die fachwelt belächelt
hat oder sich darüber empört hat die
hacks zum beispiel dass sie gesagt dass
sie es für hacks wenn wir digital
angegriffen werden durch cyber-angriffe
dass wir zurück hatten sollen dann hat
die ganze fachwelt auf gelacht dann ist
sie schnell zurück gerudert damit ist
die innenministerin bisher aufgefallen
müssen sie vielleicht erläutern der
begriff weil ich vermute mal nicht alle
ihn verstehen und ich ziehe mich damals
gerade mit das ist wenn wir angegriffen
werden durch einen cyber angriffe und
zur infrastruktur zeit dass wir die
möglichkeit haben sollen in deutschland
dass wir zurück hacken und zurück
angreifen und so das ist alles gar nicht
so einfach möglich es ist eigentlich die
dümmste mögliche chance sich tatsächlich
zu werden anstatt dafür zu sorgen dass
wir uns wehren können das werk defensive
abwehrmaßnahmen gegen cyber attacken
haben das hat die ganze fachwerkhäuser
erklärt und dementsprechend ist sie dann
auch zurückgerudert
ja das ist nicht ganz wichtig denn wir
haben die klaren prioritäten im bereich
cyber sicherheit gesetzt jetzt ist es so
heute wird der etat für das
bundesinnenministerium verabschiedet
besetzen die klaren prioritäten für das
bundesamt für sicherheit in der
informationstechnik wir haben mehr
personelle stärken die wir aufbauen
dieses bundesamt muss auch weiter
gestärkt werden und im bereich der cyber
abwehr aktiv und gut aufgestellt zu sein
das zeigen gerade die bedrohungslagen
die wir durch den russischen
angriffskrieg auf die ukraine sehen wo
es immer mehr angriffe und
unsicherheiten letztendlich auch gibt
einige beispiele haben wir in den
vergangenen wochen gesehen und von daher
wir gehen in dem bereich voran aber
nochmal eine der größten bedrohungs
herausforderung ist auch der kampf gegen
rechtsextremismus gerade durch
parteikollegen wie hyballa und andere
innerhalb der afd und das gerade hierzu
jetzt nichts gesagt worden ist das
überrascht mich jetzt nicht wie jetzt
war die gelegenheit geben auch dazu noch
ein zwei sätze zu sagen na ja so zuerst
will ich ganz gerne sagen wenn sie sagen
dass bisher soll gestärkt werden ich war
schon mal vor wenn es nicht mehr in
abhängigkeit vom innenministerium stehen
würde damit wir richtig für die
sicherheit in deutschland seien sorgen
colorado das war eine selbstständig eine
eigenständige behörde nicht abhängig vom
innenministerium das innenministerium
ist natürlich immer darauf bedacht die
hand über zu halten zu sagen wir
brauchen irgendwie hinter türen damit
was überwachen können und das bsi ist
für unsere sicherheit für unser cyber
sicherheit zuständig und und die sind
natürlich daran interessiert gewisse
lücken zu schließen und all das was dem
ministerium eigentlich widerspricht und
das passt nicht zusammen deswegen muss
das psi tatsächlich selbstständig
gestellt und ja also mein wieso her
kubala plötzlich ein rechtsextremist
sein soll dass man sich erst mal
erklären aber er hat glaube ich auch
ihren kollegen hacker erwähnt der herr
wieso hat er dem kontext hat er aber
also ich hab mir jetzt mal die zahlen
angeguckt auch in vorbereitung auf
dieses interview und er hat die
bundesanwaltschaft im letzten jahr
ermittlungsverfahren eingeleitet 210
gegen islamismus 10 gegen
linksextremismus 5 gegen
rechtsextremismus also diese aufgebaute
die größte bedrohung in deutschland ist
der rechtsextremismus das geben die
zahlen einfach nicht her dann bleiben
wir doch noch mal bei dem thema
eigentlich ganz was anderes vor an
dieser stelle aber irgendwie weil ich
jetzt einfach da auch noch mal die
andere seite zu hören wollte weil sie ja
eben auch gesagt haben erwiesen dass das
der größte gefahrenbereich sei wenn
jetzt bin ich diese wenn man diese
zahlen hört klingt es ja so als sei das
nicht so nein da muss man ganz klar
widersprechen und wir haben die
polizeiliche kriminalstatistik letztens
vorgelegt bekommen wir haben gerade den
lagebericht extremismus vorgelegt
bekommen wo ganz klar deutlich wird dass
die größte gefahr für diese demokratie
vom rechtsextremismus ausgeht von
militanten rechtsextremismus ausgeht wir
haben vergangenen jahren immer wieder
anschläge im bereich des rechts
terrorismus auch gehabt und das
sozusagen jetzt hier zu verharmlosen
nicht sicherlich an den engen
verknüpfungen der afg in dieses milieu
die zahlen sind für alle öffentlich
nachlesbar ich kann ihm merkt dem
bericht auch gerne zur verfügung stellt
ein bisschen sacharbeit tut ja ganz gut
wenn man sich dann noch weiter
informiert das meine ich deswegen
müssten sie eigentlich die zahlen parat
haben wenn sie so etwas behaupten ich
habe hier welche
2021 habe ich eigentlich schon gesagt
55.000 straftaten die polizei als
politisch motivierte gelten ein zuwachs
bei gewalttaten von 16 prozent soviel
rechtsextremistisch motivierte
straftaten ich glaube auch wie bisher
circa 22.000 judenfeindliche straftaten
plus 29 prozent einen höchststand also
das sind die offiziellen zahlen auf die
ich zugegriffen habe gestern bei der
vorwäsche dazu müssen sie gucken was
fällt in unter politische rechte
straftaten wenn ein syrischer
einwanderer ein hakenkreuz an eine wand
malt man vielleicht das und das
politische rechts und dann überlegen wir
uns mal wie sowie diesem grund zahlen
zustande kommen und wir wissen alle dass
das gewollt ist dass diese zahlen so
hoch sind dann müsste man viel mehr
differenzieren und wenn es angriffe auf
die jüdischen mitbürger bei uns in
deutschland gibt dann müssen sich die
täter auch anschauen die kommen meistens
aus dem islamischen bereich und auch das
wird er verschleiert man diese wahrheit
nicht hören möchte er wie sie ja also
jetzt ein beispiel heranzuziehen ein
syrischer einwanderer der ein hakenkreuz
auf die auf die wand merkt man muss
jetzt mal ganz kurz feststellen dass
dadurch die argumentationsgrundlage sehr
schwach ist wir können das sehr klar
sagen der mord an walter lübke hanau
halle da sind die schweren attentate
passiert die rechts terroristischen
hintergrund haben und sich hinzustellen
und das zu verharmlosen und hier keine
klare linie zu haben und eine linie zu
vertreten die von einem wirke dann auch
noch einen parteikollegen von ihnen
immer wieder instrumentalisiert wird
ausgenutzt wird das schon muss ich sagen
wirklich erschreckend heute morgen
entwirft sie einmal noch was dazu sagen
dann wechseln wir das thema
das ist eigentlich gar nicht wert ich
weiß nicht wie man inhalte mit dem
rechtsextremismus und diesen taten in
verbindung bringen kann es tut mir leid
von daher das ist das gar nicht mehr zu
entlocken lassen wir das an dieser
stelle hier so stehen er während der
verfassungsschutz in diesem kontext
nicht die eu kommission hat einen plan
eine pflicht zu erlassen für unter
internet unternehmen wie google facebook
und andere ihre seiten nach missbrauchs-
fotos und videos zu durchsuchen dieser
plan ist in der diskussion die
bundesinnenministerium hat sich
verhalten positiv geäußert zu dem ganzen
vorgang auch wenn sie sagt prävention
und strafverfolgung seien noch ein
bisschen wichtiger wie ist die position
der bundestagsfraktion dazu
haben die vorschläge aus der eu
kommission zur kenntnis genommen da ist
viel richtiges drin einiges muss man
sich aber auch noch genau anschauen weil
gerade vor dem hintergrund dass man muss
man wissen wir warten noch auf eine
entscheidung des europäischen
gerichtshofs zur vorratsdatenspeicherung
wir haben einige hinweise des ogh
bekommen dass das sogenannte quick
freeze verfahren zulässig ist oder auch
die speicherung von daten gerade bei
schwersten straftaten von daher wir
schauen sehr genau hin und sind jetzt in
enger abstimmung um auch die richtigen
und wichtigen sachen die wir brauchen im
kampf gegen den ausufernden formen des
sexuellen missbrauchs von kindern das
wäre gerade in den letzten tagen wieder
die fälle gesehen haben um hier auch
weiter voranzukommen und entsprechenden
fall in wermelskirchen an das ganze
thema firmiert frau kutter unter dem
begriff chat kontrolle in der zeit habe
ich dazu gelesen ein bisschen
irreführender begriff sagen die weil er
suggeriert dass jegliche privatsphäre
durchforstet wird der ziel ist laut der
eu allerdings ein möglichst geringer
eingriff in eben diesem bereich sie
lehnen das ganze in bausch und bogen ab
warum was ist falsch daran missbrauch zu
verhindern oder zumindest ist die
verbreitung von missbrauchs fotos oder
videos zu verhindern da dann ist erstmal
gar nichts falsch aber das leben nicht
nur ich ab das liegt die gesamte
fachwelt ab denn das für dich
tatsächlich zum üblichen argumenten ja
aber das führt tatsächlich zu
massenüberwachung und es wundert mich
ein bisschen und mich ein bisschen dass
die spd davon nicht direkt abstand nimmt
vw sei nicht aber die sec davon abstand
genommen hat die geht das auch in
verschlüsselungen hier geht es um die
privatsphäre der leute hier geht es
darum das unternehmen mit upload filter
mit allem was möglich ist die privaten
nachrichten alles was die looser posten
durchleuchten und wenn sie dann ein foto
posten oder verschicken von ihrem kind
am stand dann landet das eventuell bei
irgendwelchen ermittlungsbehörden das
geht so nicht was ist das höhere gut
private kommunikation oder schutz vor
blind für schutz von kindern das ist das
kann man so überhaupt gar nicht
gegenüber stellen dass es eben das
problem man kommt mit dem begriff
kinderpornografie man bekommt mit diesem
erschreckenden wir dürfen wo jeder sagt
natürlich wollen wir dagegen vorgehen
aber nicht alle maßnahmen sind
gerechtfertigt und eine
massenüberwachung durch die hintertür
einzuführen und als aussehen gesteht sie
sagen wir gegen die kinderpornografie
vor das geht nicht das ist gefährlich
das ist ein ganz gefährlicher wegen den
dürfen wir nicht beschreiben was ist das
höhere gut private kommunikation oder
schutz von kindern vor missbrauch ich
habe da eine klare priorität wenn ich
mir die fürchterlichen verbrechen an
kindern anschauen die ihr ganzes leben
lang darunter leiden dann müssen wir
genau hinschauen was ist rechtsstaatlich
möglich um diese täter zur rechenschaft
zu ziehen um diese schlimmen taten zu
verhindern man muss genau hinschauen was
wirkt das quick freeze verfahren kann
eine möglichkeit letztendlich sein
müssen wir vielleicht auch noch mal
entschuldigt und ganz kurz wenigstens
noch ein hartes wort verwenden dass wir
darum daten relativ schnell zu sichern
für einen bestimmten zeitraum wenn ich
es richtig in erinnerung habe genau wenn
anhaltspunkte ermittlungsansatz punkte
da sind das sozusagen daten ip-adressen
eingefroren werden damit die
ermittlungsbehörden die möglichkeit
haben darauf zuzugreifen und im bereich
von schwersten straftaten auch die
speicherung ip adressen ist ein
vorschlag den nancy faeser gerade
gemacht hat auch umzusetzen wie gesagt
meine klare priorität ist der schutz der
kinder hier müssen vorangehen hier
müssen wir auch noch mehr tun und dass
die afg schwierigkeiten mit der
veröffentlichung von chat protokollen
hat das haben wir ja gerade erst in der
vergangenheit gesehen aber die werden ja
auch so versprechen ganz kurz vor ihrem
100 so erklären auch nochmal der
zuschauerin die nicht ganz so tief drin
sind die speicherung von ip-adressen
deshalb interessant weil die auf einen
bestimmten rechner von eben aus
irgendetwas veröffentlicht worden ist
zurückweisen die aber relativ schnell
wechseln können auch unter so und
deswegen muss man die sicherheit dann
wird man das weiter nachverfolgt und
jetzt dürfen sie ganz kurz das stellung
beziehen digital ausschuss hat ihr
koalitionspartner die fdp damit hast
diese chat kontrollen so wie sie jetzt
geplant ist gegen den koalitionsvertrag
verstoßen und ich wäre dankbar und froh
wenn die spd das auf dem schirm hätte
was würden sie denn machen wenn diese
fälle die sie ja offensichtlich auch
verurteilen irgendwie um sowas zu
verhindern einzudämmen zu verfolgen auch
die täter dingfest zu machen und alles
was dazugehört wenn dieser bereich der
versuch der strafverfolgung ausfällt was
sind ihre alternativvorschläge das ist
das was ich generell sagen bei
straftaten im internet das was was
analog verboten ist es im internet
verboten und wir müssen unsere justiz
und unsere polizei in die lage versetzen
dass sie dem tatsächlich nachgehen kann
wir haben zu wenig personal wir haben zu
wenig gut ausgebildetes personal da
müssen wir massiv aufstocken dass sie
sich auch im sommer haben sich bewegen
und dementsprechend auch richtig
ermitteln können das ist die aufgabe
unserer behörden und den müssen sie
nachkommen aber bitte nicht jeden bürger
unter generalverdacht stellen und seine
private nachrichten an der stelle
vermutlich mal sind sie ja durchaus
einig dass es da mehr personal braucht
wir um die fälle im ordnungsgemäß
nachzuverfolgen warum man trotzdem noch
dieser zusätzliche weg weil wir
letztendlich auf der einen seite
natürlich personal möglichkeiten von
künstlicher intelligenz brauchen um
diese schiere anzahl an daten überhaupt
er letztendlich auch hier zu werden aber
ich habe im internet die herausforderung
dass die täter sozusagen sich verstecken
können nicht gefunden werden können den
möglichkeiten die das internet ihnen
momentan gibt nutzt und diese straftaten
zu begehen und da muss ich ganz deutlich
sagen wir müssen wir die möglichkeiten
die rechtsstaatlich zulässig sind nutzen
um diesen tätern die diese perfiden
taten begehen dingfest zu werden
handhabt zu werden und die kinder zu
schützen das ist eine klare priorität
und da bin ich sehr eindeutig und hab
dann nicht so eine an auffassung für die
kollegen im ziel wahrscheinlich einig
über die art und weise sehr
unterschiedliche auffassungen das haben
wir jetzt gerade auch noch mal gemerkt
wie so vielen dank dass ich heute morgen
bei uns gewesen sind auch ihnen frau
kutter vielen dank in diskussion wir
gleich im plenum fortgesetzt wenn ich
vermute mal ein wirklich auch zu diesem
thema wald zu kommen zu den aktuell
diskutierten gehören vielen dank für
heute morgen und wir meine damen und
herren schauen schon mal in den
plenarsaal hinein denn da fühlen sich so
langsam ihr ein ich habe schon gesagt
einzelplan zum innenministerium ist der
erste der hier heute diskutiert werden
wird auf der tagesordnung aber auch ganz
viele weitere wichtige
details beispielsweise der für
wirtschaft und klimaschutz auch da
können wir eine interessante debatte
erwarten außerdem nicht zu
vernachlässigen die bereiche
ernährung und landwirtschaft auch das
durch den krieg in der ukraine bedingt
natürlich ein großes und weites feld
weil es im moment auch einige krisen
gibt oder dass ich einige krisen sich
entwickeln in der welt was die ernährung
angeht die ernährungslage weil es
einfach an rohstoffen und
nahrungsmitteln fehlt weil etwa weizen
zurückgehalten wird oder nicht geliefert
werden kann etwa aus der ukraine wir
sehen die bundestagspräsidentin auf dem
weg zu ihrem platz und das bedeutet ich
kann schon mal reingeben ins plenum
sehr geehrte damen und herren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen ich wünsche
allen einen schönen guten morgen die
sitzung ist eröffnet
vor eintritt in die tagesordnung
gratuliere ich der kollegin marianne
schieder nachträglich zu ihrem
sechzigsten geburtstag alles gute im
namen des ganzen haus
dann haben wir vorab noch einige wahlen
durchzuführen in den
vermittlungsausschuss soll auf vorschlag
der fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen der
abgeordnete andreas drysch als
nachfolger für die abgeordnete lisa paus
als stellvertretendes mitglied gewählt
werden ich gehe davon aus sie sind damit
einverstanden keine
gegenstimmen dann ist das so damit ist
der kollege andreas dresch als
stellvertretendes mitglied des
vermittlungsausschusses
gewählt in den verwaltungsrat bei der
bundesanstalt für
finanzdienstleistungsaufsicht soll auf
vorschlag der fraktion bündnis 90 die
grünen der abgeordnete sascha müller als
nachfolger für die abgeordnete lisa paus
als ordentliches mitglied gewählt werden
auch hierzu sehe ich keinen widerspruch
dann ist der kollege sascha müller als
ordentliches mitglied des
verwaltungsrates bei der bundesanstalt
für
finanzdienstleistungsaufsicht gewählt
außerdem soll in den verwaltungsrat des
deutsch französischen jugendwerks auf
vorschlag der fraktionen der cdu/csu die
abgeordnete diana stöcker als
nachfolgerin für den ausgeschiedenen
abgeordneten mattern von marshall als
ordentliches mitglied für den rest der
amtszeit gewählt werden auch dem stimmen
sie zu
das sieht so aus kein widerspruch dann
ist das der fall dann ist die kollegin
diana stöcker als ordentliches mitglied
des verwaltungsrates gewählt
schließlich soll für die evaluation nach
§ 5 absatz 9 des
infektionsschutzgesetzes auf vorschlag
der fraktion der cdu/csu der
sachverständige professor dr klaus stöhr
als nachfolger für den ausgeschiedenen
sachverständigen professor dr christian
drosten gewählt werden auch hierzu sehe
ich keinen widerspruch
dann ist herr professor dr stöhr als
sachverständiger für die evaluation nach
§ 5 absatz 9 des
infektionsschutzgesetzes
gewählt
wir setzen die haushaltsberatungen fort
ich rufe auf die einzelpläne 0 6 und 21
für das bundesministerium des innern und
für heimat das ist der einzelplan 06 mit
den beschlussempfehlungen
des haushaltsausschusses auf den
drucksachen
1606 und
1626 und bundesbeauftragter für den
datenschutz und die informationsfreiheit
das ist der einzelplan 21 mit den
beschlussempfehlungen des
haushaltsausschusses auf den drucksachen
1626 und
berichterstattung zu den beiden
einzelplänen haben die abgeordneten
jamila schäfer martin gerster doktor
andré berghegger dr thorsten lieb markus
buhl und victor perli
zu dem einzelplan 06 liegt je ein
änderungsantrag der fraktionen der
cdu/csu und der fraktion der afg vor für
die aussprache wurde eine dauer von 90
minuten vereinbart ich eröffne hiermit
die aussprache und als erster hat das
wort für die cdu csu fraktion dr andré
berghegger
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte ministerin feser ihre
kolleginnen und kollegen meine damen und
herren wie kann ein donnerstagmorgen in
einer haushaltswoche schöner beginnen
als mit der debatte des einzelplan 10 6
ich kann mir kaum was anderes vorstellen
intent
so hat stimmt das schon mal intensiver
haushaltsberatungen liegen hinter uns
und wir werden ende der woche einen
haushalt für das jahr 2022 beschließen
der ehrlicherweise nur ein halbes jahr
gültigkeit hat das müssen wir uns immer
wieder bewusst machen bis jetzt galt die
vorläufige haushaltsführung in diesem
zusammenhang dankt an das
innenministerium sehr geehrte frau
ministerin und an ihre mitarbeiterinnen
und mitarbeiter sie haben jederzeit
umfassend und zügig alle fragen
beantwortet das hat die arbeit sehr
erleichtert vielen dank an dieser stelle
erlauben sie mir einige grundlegende
anmerkungen zum haushalt im allgemeinen
bevor ich dann auf den einzelplan 0 6 1
geben werde ich zitiere mit erlaubnis
der präsidentin wir antworten auf die
ökonomische zeitenwende aufgrund der
inflation durch die rückkehr zu soliden
haushalten und das ende immer neue
schulden so wartet der finanz solltest
der finanzminister lindner am dienstag
in der allgemeinen finanzdebatte gesagt
ehrlicherweise spekuliert er hier leider
nur über den haushalt 2 23 denn der
haushalt
2022 ist natürlich das komplette
gegenteil davon das kann man auch in den
zahlen nicht schönreden das weiß ja auch
nur er redet nicht zu ende da drüber das
volumen dieses haushaltes beträgt 500
milliarden euro eine unvorstellbare
summe für die zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer an den bildschirm und
natürlich auch hier im saal davon werden
alleine rund 140 milliarden euro an
krediten auf 140 milliarden das sind
140000 millionen um das nur noch mal
deutlicher zu machen auch eine
gigantische summe dazu werden wir das
sondervermögen der bundeswehr noch zu
zählen haben das allein bedeutet in
diesem jahr weitere 200 milliarden euro
an krediten die irgendwann mit zins und
tilgung zurück zu zahlen sind und zu
bedienen warum sage ich dass der
finanzielle spielraum für die allgemeine
schuldenbremse in normalform beträgt
derzeit rund 23 milliarden euro und er
ist alleine durch die zurückzahlung der
korona sonderkredite aus dem letzten
jahr durch die durch die finanzielle
verpflichtung bei dem programm next
generation eu schon mit 15 bis 16
milliarden euro belegt das zeigt glaube
ich eine anmerkung zum nachdenken wie
eng der finanzielle spielraum und die
finanzpolitische verantwortung in den
nächsten jahren zu sehen ist
insbesondere wenn wir die schuldenbremse
einhalten wollen
liebe vertreterinnen der ampelkoalition
ich bin der festen überzeugung sie
können nicht einfach den
koalitionsvertrag abarbeiten und die
risiken finanzpolitischen
herausforderungen aus der korona
pandemie und aus den auswirkungen des
ukraine krieges on top setzen diese
rechnung wird schwer aufgeben sie werden
prioritäten setzen müssen die devise
wird sein pflicht vor kür wenn sie sich
auf das wesentliche konzentrieren und
wenn sie die schuldenbremse einhalten
einhalten werden oder es versuchen das
begrüßen wir das natürlich natürlich
werden wir aber dabei auch andere
thematische schwerpunkte setzen wenn sie
aber weiter in den verschuldungsstaat
gehen zu lasten der nachfolgenden
generation werden wir wachsam sein und
versuchen sie auf den pfad der tugend
zurückzubringen die vergangenheit hat
doch gezeigt dass unter federführung
beginnend mit dem finanzminister
schäuble als besonderes beispiel hat
doch gezeigt wie wichtig finanzielle
polster sind um resilient zu sein und
handlungsfähig in schwierigen zeiten
darauf müssen wir überall
zum einzelplan 06 im besonderen dazu
gibt es natürlich viel zu sagen von
ministerin mit ihren vielen
nachgeordneten behörden
selbstverständlich für die unions
fraktion kann ich glaube ich sagen dass
wir natürlich die stärkung der inneren
sicherheit im engeren sinne unterstützen
das steht außer frage so wurde im mittel
aufwuchs als auch den ställen aufwuchs
hier seien die 1000 zusätzlichen stellen
bei der bundespolizei besonders zu
erwähnen aber man muss auch deutlich
sagen es wäre mehr machbar gewesen bei
der inneren sicherheit es wäre mehr
machbar gewesen und das ohne
finanziellen mehraufwand im vergleich zu
jetzt sie verhalten sich aus meiner
sicht an zwei punkten widersprüchlich
und das möchte ich gerne verdeutlich
nehmen auf der einen seite haben sie
eine art finanzpolitische
torschlusspanik und nehmen das geld was
wir bekommen können das erkennt man an
der neuen rücklage für unvorhergesehene
bedarf für unter anderem beim thw beim
bundesamt für bevölkerungsschutz und
katastrophenhilfe diese rücklage ist den
ergänzungs haushalt geschaffen worden
und hat die konkrete summe 34 millionen
und 79.000 euro
zum gesamtbild zur vollständigkeit
gehört nur dazu sie parken hier schlicht
die rechts die restsumme der viertel
milliarde euro die der finanzminister
für das bmi vorgesehen hat ohne dass sie
hierzu aktuell einen bedarf haben
das finde ich ehrlicherweise nicht
seriös konsequent wäre aus ihrer sicht
gewesen wenn sie die mittel derzeit
nicht benötigen da sie keinen zweck der
derzeit dafür vorsehen dann nehmen sie
die mittel gar nicht in anspruch da
würde ein haushälter sagen dass es
sparsame und wirtschaftliche
haushaltsführung
das haben sie leider nicht getan
aber die noch viel bessere lösung wäre
gewesen sie hätten einfach auch unseren
anträgen zur stärkung des bbk auch in
diesen bereichen zustimmen können da
haben wir diverse vorschläge gemacht das
ist doch logisch wir haben die bereiche
zivile verteidigung bevölkerungsschutz
katastrophenhilfe das haben wir doch
aufstocken wollen haben das stärken
wollen das steht außer frage das haben
wir frühzeitig in vielen gesprächen
deutlich gemacht erfreulich ist dass die
ampel im laufe der haushaltsberatung die
ein oder andere idee aufgenommen hat und
entsprechende deckblätter formuliert hat
die konnten wir dann logischerweise
mittragen und wir konnten es ertragen
leider nur um mit schmerz dass wir
unsere deckblätter dann abgelehnt haben
aber das ging in die richtige richtung
so wirkt konstruktive opposition
auch auf der anderen seite bedenken sie
aber frau ministerin wir hatten doch den
missglückten beantragt 2020 die
flutkatastrophe im aartal und
schließlich spüren wir alle die
auswirkungen die schrecklichen aus der
ukraine situation aus dem krieg in der
ukraine es wird doch immer deutlicher
und wichtig wie wichtig entsprechende
informationen der bevölkerung
rechtzeitige warnungen und hinweise sind
wenn dann aber von dem erforderlichen
bedarf das bbk für die nina wann apple
für cell broadcast systeme für das
modulare warnsystem mofas und bei der
unterstützung moderner sirenen ohne
dabei die länder aus der verantwortung
zu lassen das wird der kollege gerstner
sicherlich gleich wieder zurecht
ansprechen ohne die länder aus der
verantwortung zu lassen wenn aber von
dem angemeldeten bedarf nur rund die
hälfte bewilligt wird dann habe ich
fragen und der bedarf ist doch von den
fachleuten angemeldet worden hier hätten
sie die mittel aus der rücklage
einsetzen können ohne finanziellen
aufwand ihr wäre es sinnvoll angelegt
worden so ist das aus meiner sicht das
falsche signal
und da uns dieser punkt so wichtig ist
frau präsidentin hat es vorhin
angesprochen und da uns dieser punkt so
wichtig ist werden wir bis zum schluss
einen entsprechenden änderungsantrag
aufrechterhalten ich lege es noch einmal
den abgeordneten kolleginnen und
kollegen der koalition noch einmal
drüber nachzudenken sie haben noch
anderthalb stunden zeit wir wollen
weiterhin eine stärkung eine stärkung in
diesem bereich und deswegen stellen wir
diesen änderungsantrag zur abstimmung an
die fdp insbesondere appelliere ich
natürlich setzen sie sich weiter oder
vielleicht kann man auch sagen wieder
für eine seriöse haushalts und
fiskalpolitik ein und achten sie darauf
nächstes jahr die schuldenbremse wieder
einzuhalten vergessen sie nicht was sie
vor der wahl immer vehement kritisiert
haben unseriöse finanzen
schattenhaushalte hohe reste und der
gang in den schuldenstaat dieser
einzelplan hat noch luft hier rw nicht
nur die im vergleich zu anderen
einzelplänen zweitgrößten haushaltsreste
die hier vorliegen ist nur einer von
mehreren konsolidierungsbeiträge so
senden sie unglückliche signale setzen
aus meiner sicht falsche prioritäten und
deswegen werden wir den einzelplan
ablegen ablehnen und denken sie zum
schluss daran nicht nur hier sondern im
gesamten haushalt jede zeitenwende muss
auch nachhaltig finanziert werden ziehen
sie nächstes jahr wieder die
schuldenbremse das sind wir unseren
kindern schuldig vielen dank fürs
freundliche zugang
andré berghegger war das aus der
unionsfraktion zu den zahlen zum geld
und damit auch zur grundlage für die
arbeit des bundesministerium des innern
und für heimat zu den politischen
vorhaben die damit umgesetzt werden
sollen jetzt die verantwortliche
ministerin nancy faeser
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine
damen und herren abgeordnete sehr
geehrte damen und herren zuschauerin
zuschauer wir haben seit mehreren
monaten nun leider schrecklichen krieg
angriffskrieg putins in der ukraine und
deswegen möchte ich zu beginn meiner
haushaltsrede denjenigen danken die im
moment großartiges leisten sei es die
helferinnen und helfer des thw es
dienstleistungen in die ukraine selbst
fahren die vor ort unterwegs sind zu
unterstützen und die vielen tausend
flüchtlings helferinnen und helfer die
großartiges leisten bei der aufnahme der
ukrainischen geflüchteten herzlichen
dank dafür
neben dem furchtbaren krieg mitten in
europa kämpfen wir noch immer mit den
auswirkungen der korona pandemie immer
häufiger kommt es zu extremen
wetterereignissen die
lebenshaltungskosten und vor allen
dingen die energiekosten steigen das
alles beschäftigt die menschen in
deutschland sehr und viele machen sich
auch darüber sorgen sie machen sich
sorgen weil es hier nicht mit abstrakten
bedrohung zu tun haben sondern diese
bedrohung wirken sich sehr konkret auf
ihren alltag aus sie sind sehr viel
spürbarer als in der vergangenheit und
es ist die zentrale aufgabe des staates
die menschen vor diesen bedrohungen zu
schützen meine damen und herren
für mich als bundesministerin hat auch
deshalb die sicherheit aller menschen in
unserem land oberste priorität ganz
gleich wie viel geld sie haben wo ihre
familien einmal herkamen sicherheit ist
aus meiner sicht eine frage der sozialen
gerechtigkeit und angesichts der
aktuellen krisen müssen wir deutlich
mehr für die sicherheit tun
wir haben in den letzten jahren viel
zeit mit innenpolitischen debatten
verschwendet die nicht besonders
zielführend waren dabei wurde oft mit
gefühlter sicherheit argumentiert mir
geht es um tatsächliche sicherheit
mit dem hause
2022 gehen die große schritte zu diesem
ziel er sieht für den einzelplan des
bundesinnenministeriums ein
gesamtvolumen von rund 15 milliarden
euro vor das ist ein plus von rund 8 189
millionen euro im vergleich zum entwurf
der vorgängerregierung und mit dem
ergänzungs haushalt kommen noch einmal
250 millionen euro für die folgen des
krieges in der ukraine hinzu dass es
gelungen ist so viele geflüchtete in so
kurzer zeit aufzunehmen zu schützen und
zu versorgen das ist eine großartige
leistung unseres gesamten landes meine
damen und herren
mit den zusätzlichen mitteln und neun
stellen stärken wir alle politikbereiche
des bundesinnenministeriums besonders
die kriminalitätsbekämpfung den
bevölkerungsschutz und die
cybersicherheit das bedeutet mehr
sicherheit für die menschen in der
bundesrepublik
konsequente kriminalitätsbekämpfung
heißt im umgang mit dem organisierten
verbrechen eine deutlich härtere gangart
einzulegen organisierte kriminalität ist
zwar oft weniger sichtbar als
terrorismus oder extremismus aber sie
ist genauso gefährlich das bka verstärkt
deshalb die bekämpfung von organisierter
kriminalität clan und rockerkriminalität
unter anderem mit konsequenten finanz
ermittlungen um illegales vermögens
schnell einzuziehen so können wir
kriminelle strukturen frühzeitig
erkennen und zu zerschlagen und das ist
auch zwingend gut wenn
meine damen und herren es besonders
wichtig dass wir die verwundbarsten in
unserer gesellschaft besser schützen das
entsetzliche ausmaße sexuelle
sexualisierter gewalt gegen kinder macht
mir sehr große sorgen und fordert ein
konsequentes handeln wir brauchen den
höchstmöglichen ermittlungsdruck um die
täter und ihre netzwerke aufzudecken und
vor allen dingen die kinder zu schützen
dafür werden wir auch europäische
instrumente schaffen wir werden dabei
die private kommunikation der menschen
die mit diesen verbrechen überhaupt
nichts zu tun haben aber auch weiter
schützen mir geht es um ein sehr
gezieltes und sehr konsequentes vorgehen
gegen die täter und ihre netzwerke kein
täter darf sich sicher fühlen vor
strafverfolgung meine damen
ich bin deshalb auch froh dass wir für
die beiden behörden die vorrangig
kriminalitätsbekämpfung zuständig sind
große stellen auf mütze erreichen
konnten das bundeskriminalamt der held
435 neue stellen die bundespolizei das
hat herr dr berger ja schon gesagt über
1000 neue stellen das ist auch gut und
richtig und da darf ich mich bei der cdu
auch für die unterstützung an dieser
stelle bedanken meine damen und herren
wir erleben im moment eine vielzahl von
krisen und bedrohungen gleichzeitig das
bedeutet aber dass der
bevölkerungsschutz in deutschland auch
einen höheren stellenwert bekommen muss
hier ist es in vergangenen jahren und
jahrzehnten viel zu wenig passiert oder
sogar das gegenteil ich denke an den
abbau den sirenen im ganzen land mit dem
haushalt
2022 investieren wir deshalb erheblich
im bevölkerungsschutz und
katastrophenhilfe wir sorgen für moderne
warnsystem in die naz angesprochen
worden mit jenen die ihn mit denen jeder
präzise warnung direkt aufs handy
bekommt wir bauen neue logistikzentren
für das thw auf und wir verstärken die
zivilschutz reserve des bundes
insbesondere mit einem massiven aufwuchs
auch durch den ergänzungs haushalt im
bereich des projektes labor 5000 für
diejenigen die nicht wissen was es ist
ein großes infrastrukturprojekt was in
jeder krisenlage angewandt werden kann
mit zelten mit wasser abwasser system
mit eigener haushalts prozess mit
containersystem sehr wichtig für alle
formen der krise und ich darf mich bei
den haushälterinnen haushältern der
ampel koalition sehr herzlich für die
unterstützung an dieser stelle bedanken
denn meine damen und herren im ernstfall
muss der staat handlungsfähig sein bei
kriegsbedingten gefahren bei
extremwetter ereignissen oder bei
stromausfällen auch unsere kritische
infrastruktur müssen im ernstfall
funktionieren unsere stadtwerken unsere
krankenhäuser unsere transportwege wir
sehen im moment darüber hinaus eine
große gefahr die insbesondere vom
angriff stick aus der ukraine kommt im
bereich der cyber angriffe auf genau
diese kritische infrastruktur deshalb
haben wir die schutzmaßnahmen massiv
hochgefahren
noch vor der sommerpause werde ich meine
cyber sicherheitsstrategie vorstellen
dazu gehört unter anderem dass wir dem
bund die führende rolle in der cyber
sicherheit geben und das auch im
grundgesetz verankern dafür wer habe ich
bereits jetzt denn komplexe
cyberattacken kann nur der bund effektiv
etwas entgegen setzen wir haben mit dem
nationalen cyber abwehrzentrum sehr viel
expertise die wir mit diesem
vorliegenden haushalt noch weiter
ausbauen
in der bereinigungssitzung hat der
haushaltsausschuss aus meiner sicht noch
weitere wichtige akzente gesetzt
der ausschuss hat 25 millionen für ein
humanitäres aufnahmeprogramm für
besonders gefährdete menschen aus
afghanistan bereitgestellt auch für die
bekämpfung von antisemitismus wurden die
mittel noch einmal gehört erhöht ich
komme gerade aus israel und meine damen
und herren wir müssen unsere jüdischen
mitbürgerinnen und mitbürger mehr
schützen in unserem land da haben wir
eine große verpflichtung
besonders aber freue ich mich dass der
ausschuss 25 millionen euro für das
programm neustart des sports nach corona
bereitgestellt hat die pandemie hat die
sportvereine sehr hart getroffen in der
bundesrepublik dass sie nun dabei
unterstützt werden endlich wieder
durchzustarten ist ein klares bekenntnis
auch zum breitensport in der
bundesrepublik deutschland und dafür
darf ich den haushälterinnen haushältern
der ampel koalition sehr herzlich danken
meine damen und herren dieser haushalt
ist gut für die menschen und für die
sicherheit der rat die in deutschland
leben es schafft die basis dafür dass
das bundesinnenministerium für unsere
vorhaben rückenwind bekommt ich möchte
deshalb noch einmal ganz herzlich
bedanken bei den haushaltspolitischen
sprecherinnen und sprechern der
koalition denn es wurde sven christian
kindler und otto fricke sowie die für
den einzelplan des bmi zuständige
berichterstatterin der koalition janina
schäfer thorsten lieb und martin gerster
aber ich habe es gesagt ich möchte mich
auch bei herrn dr bergheim pauli von der
opposition für die konstruktive beratung
sehr herzlich bedanken
meine damen und herren mein dank geht
aber vor allen dingen den vielen
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter meines
hauses die hervorragende arbeit in sehr
schwierigen zeiten leisten und mein dank
gilt zum abschluss natürlich auch
finanzminister christian lindner für die
unterstützung all dieser vorhaben herzen
dank für ihre aufmerksamkeit danke für
die unterstützung der sicherheit der
menschen in unserem land
rechtsextremismus organisierte
kriminalität pädokriminalität der
bevölkerungsschutz das sind die
wichtigsten punkte gewesen in dem
beitrag vom bundesinnenministerium nancy
faeser aber natürlich auch der sport
denn das innenministerium ist
traditionell auch für den sport in
deutschland zuständige markus mühle ist
der nächste redner aus der fdp-fraktion
präsidentin sehr geehrte damen und
herren die gewährleistung der inneren
sicherheit ist einer der wichtigsten
aufgaben eines staates was wir
allerdings in 16 jahren merkel erlebt
haben und jetzt mit der links gelben
regierung erleben ist ein zunehmend
funktionsunfähige staat der immer
weniger in der lage ist seine
kernaufgaben wahrzunehmen der
vorliegende bundeshaushalt für
innenpolitik und heimat ist mit seiner
mittelverteilung
ein erschreckendes beispiel dafür links
gelbe prioritätensetzungen wie bei den
betrugs anfälligen sprach und
integrationskursen glücklich mit
deutschem steuergeld ausgestattet
während der grenzschutz weiterhin völlig
unzureichend ist und es viel zu wenige
neue
bundespolizisten gibt
bleiben wir gleich bei der bundespolizei
1000 zusätzliche stellen sind ein anfang
aber bevor diese verstärkung kommt
müssen drei jahre ausbildung durchlaufen
werden und jährlich geht vor allem in
den kommenden jahren ein beträchtlicher
teil der beamten in den ruhestand daher
gleicht die netto verstärkung
hauptsächlich die altersbedingten
abgänge aus von den neuen polizisten die
dieses jahr bei der bundespolizei fertig
ausgebildet sind werden viele in den
ballungszentren mit hohen mieten
versetzt werden bieten die sich die
jungen polizei absolventen oft nicht
leisten können und so wohngemeinschaften
bilden oder lange strecken pendeln
müssen wir haben daher einen antrag zur
einführung von orts zuschlägen in
großstädten für die jungen absolventen
gestellt kommen wir zum thema
einwanderung
2022 sollen die mittel für integrations-
und sprachkurse
675 millionen euro umfassen durchgeführt
von circa
1.500 trägern die große sind zu einem
enormen geschäfts und
beschäftigungsmodell geworden vehement
verteidigt von den verfechtern der
politik der offenen grenzen schauen wir
auf die abrechnung bei diesen kursen und
fließt eigentlich nur dann geld an die
bildungsträger wenn die teilnehmer
anwesend sind und dies mit ihrer
unterschrift dokumentiert haben es
bedarf allerdings keine hellseher um zu
erkennen dass dieses konstrukt zum
betrug geradezu einlädt zum beispiel
unterschriften nachträglich zu leisten
oder zu beginnen und dann nicht am
unterricht teilzunehmen im jahr 2020
erreichen laut innenministerium 48
prozent der kursteilnehmer das
sprachniveau b1 nicht das wäre
allerdings notwendig für den
arbeitsmarkt die steigende zahl von
transferempfängern die deutsche sprache
nicht beherrschen bedeutet enorme lasten
für den sozialstaat also für den
deutschen steuerzahler
frau ministerin ich fordere sie fordern
sie dringend auf aufgrund dieser
erschreckenden ergebnisse wirksam zu
handeln ihre behörde das bundesamt für
migration und flüchtlinge hat hier
umfassende kontrollen
sanktionsinstrumente einzusetzen damit
die teilnehmerzahlen richtig abgerechnet
werden und wer danach weiter wer
nachweislich keine perspektive
deutschland hat braucht auch keinen
teuren integrationskurs
der bundesrechnungshof führt in seinem
bericht über die integrationsmaßnahmen
des bundes doppelförderung und die nicht
erreichung der gesteckten ziele an frau
ministerin nehmen sie diesen bericht
ernst eine weitere absurdität ist die
förderung der freiwilligen ausreise im
ergänzungs haushalt wird dieser zuschuss
um 20 millionen auf dann 59 millionen
euro erhöht es werden also personen die
zur ausreise rechtlich verpflichtet sind
mit prämien ausgestattet wenn sie sich
rechtskonform verhalten wie wenig
willens diese links gelbe
bundesregierung ist geltendes recht mit
den völlig normalen mitteln eines
rechtsstaates durchzusetzen zeigt dieses
beispiel sehr sehr eindrücklich
auch hier wird stattdessen steuergeld in
größenordnungen verschwendet wir werden
dem haushaltsplan daher nicht zustimmen
ich danke ihnen für ihre aufmerksamkeit
nächste rednerin für die fraktion
bündnis 90/die grünen jamila skifahren
und jamila schäfer ist mitglied im
haushaltsausschuss und
berichterstatterin ihrer fraktion zu
diesem themenfeld
schülerinnen und schüler auf der bühne
zurück zur sache bei diesen beratungen
zum bundeshaushalt mussten wir natürlich
den gestiegenen
sicherheitspolitischen anforderungen
schnell im laufenden verfahren gerecht
werden deshalb haben wir mit dem
ergänzungs haushalt von insgesamt über
26 milliarden euro und im
parlamentarischen verfahren
nachgesteuert und übernehmen
verantwortung für die sicherheit unserer
bevölkerung
der kriege in der ukraine
er hat natürlich gestiegene
verteidigungsausgaben notwendig gemacht
im ernstfall brauchen wir aber auch
einen funktionierenden zivilschutz
innerhalb deutschlands ganz egal ob es
um krieg geht oder um naturkatastrophen
fehlende bahnsysteme kosten
menschenleben das hat uns nicht zuletzt
die flutkatastrophe im aartal im letzten
jahr schmerzlich vor augen geführt
deshalb ist es wichtig dass wir uns
bundesweit für eine funktionierende
waren infrastruktur einsetzen und dass
ihr das thw und das bundesamt für
bevölkerungsschutz und katastrophenhilfe
jetzt nochmal mit jeweils 50 millionen
euro im ergebnishaushalt gestärkt haben
im parlamentarischen verfahren
haben wir dieses stärken jetzt auch noch
mal auf
33,5 millionen euro ausgebaut das
bundesamt für bevölkerungsschutz und
katastrophenhilfe kann jetzt zum
beispiel den ausbildungsstandort in
stralsund endlich in betrieb nehmen
entscheidungen katastrophenfällen zu
treffen braucht nämlich eine angemessene
schule und übung der staat darf die
einsatzkräfte und
entscheidungsträger innen nicht allein
lassen und dafür werden wir gemeinsam
sorgen
wir müssen natürlich aber auch die
erheblichen sicherheitslücken bei der
cyber security noch schließen menschen
leben stehen auf dem spiel wenn
krankenhäuser oder unsere
wasserversorgung ohne schutz bleiben bei
der finanzierung haben wir hier noch
eine große aufgabe vor uns aber ich bin
mir sicher dass wir sie gemeinsam
meistern werden für die sicherheit und
weiterentwicklung unserer it stehen wir
stellen wir in diesem haushalt auch noch
einmal insgesamt 50 millionen euro zur
verfügung denn die zukunft eisdaten
souveränität und open source
zu einer verantwortungsvollen politik
gehört ist aber auch diejenigen zu
schützen die mit ihrer arbeit für unsere
sicherheit ihre eigene in gefahr
gebracht haben ja damit meine ich die
ortskräfte und die
menschenrechtsverteidigerinnen in
afghanistan nach 20 jahren
bundeswehreinsatz tragen wir weiterhin
eine große verantwortung für diejenigen
die hoffnung in uns gesetzt haben und
deren leben dort nun bedroht ist und
deshalb freue ich mich dass wir für die
aufnahme von besonders gefährdeten
menschen in afghanistan zusätzliche
gelder bereitstellen das ermöglicht
besonders gefährdete person zu
evakuieren ist das bundes
aufnahmeprogramm aus dem
koalitionsvertrag endlich fertig
aufgestellt ist am geld wird die
evakuierung jedenfalls nicht scheitern
dafür haben wir auch in diesem
bundeshaushalt gesorgt
zu meiner vorausschauende
migrationspolitik gehört es natürlich
auch die migrationsberatung zu stärken
und zu entbürokratisieren
hier hat leider die letzte
bundesregierung oft erst nachgesteuert
wenn es schon zu spät war die ampel
macht es umgekehrt wir lassen diejenigen
die tagtäglich dafür sorgen dass
geflüchtete hier gut ankommen können
nicht im stich die ampel macht eine
zeitgemäße innenpolitik das haben wir im
haushaltsausschuss mit unseren anträgen
in höhe von insgesamt 155 millionen euro
auch noch einmal unterstrichen ich
bedanke mich ganz herzlich bei meinen
mit berichterstattern ganz insbesondere
noch mal bei martin gerster und thorsten
lieb aber natürlich auch der
innenministerin fraser und ihrem haus
für die konstruktiven beratungen wir
werden diesem einzelplan
selbstverständlich zustimmen vielen dank
jamila schäfer für die fraktion bündnis
90/die grünen in der debatte des
bundestags über den einzelplan im 06 der
verbunden diskutiert wird mit dem
einzelplan 21 das ist der für den
datenschutzbeauftragten und in dieser
debatte jetzt martina renner aus der
linksfraktion sprecherin für
innenpolitik
viel zu späten und immer noch nicht
glücklich beendet eine evakuierung von
rotz kräften und gefährdeten personen
aus afghanistan hat die koalition nun
ein aufnahmeprogramm für das land
vereinbart das begrüßen wir ganz
deutlich hierfür sind aber lediglich 25
millionen euro eingestellt das reicht
nach eigenen berechnungen des
innenministeriums gerade mal für die
aufnahme von 5000 menschen wir sprechen
also von 1000 gefährdeten personen und
ihren engsten familienangehörigen
nach meinem von menschenrechts
organisationen müssen aber mehrere
10.000 für schutzsuchende so schnell wie
möglich vor den taliban in sicherheit
gebracht werden wir sagen es darf kein
aufnahmeprogramm nach kassenlage geben
meine damen und herren im haushalt sind
erneut mehr stellen für die
sicherheitsbehörden vorgesehen das
bundeskriminalamt kann so finde ich auch
gerne fachlich geeignete mitarbeiter und
mitarbeiterinnen einstellen die sich zum
beispiel um hass kriminalität im
internet kümmern oder personal für die
notwendige strafverfolgung von in der
ukraine begangenen kriegsverbrechen das
ist richtig aber zuerst muss auf die
frage geantwortet werden warum es zu
lange dauert die noch offenen stellen zu
besetzen
hier muss gehandelt werden ich finde
dann sollte man über das geld reden
zur bundespolizei
die bundespolizei verdoppelte die zahl
der anlasslosen kontrollen im letzten
jahr verdoppelte das muss man sich
vorstellen aber zeitgleich fehlt das
personal zum beispiel bei der
verhinderung und verfolgung von
angriffen von neonazis auf züge in
sachsen am ersten mal es ist so glaube
ich keine frage des budgets sondern der
prioritätensetzung halten wir fest
mehr beamtinnen und beamten schaffen
nicht automatisch mehr sicherheit
mit blick auf den haushalt stellen sich
mir noch weitere fragen was ist
eigentlich mit den fehlenden polizei
beauftragten für die polizeibehörden des
bundes was geschieht mit der
überwachungs gesamtrechnung das
prestigeobjekt scheint ja zwischen den
ministerien zerredet zu werden rom
zuletzt mich hat die tage die aussage
meiner kollegin linda teuteberg in einem
interview zum demokratie fördergesetz
wirklich irritiert es sieht danach aus
als müssten die zivilgesellschaftlichen
projekte erneut nach der letzten
legislatur sorge haben dass dieses
gesetzesvorhaben nicht umgesetzt wird
der kampf gegen neonazis rassismus und
antisemitismus ist aber staatsaufgabe
und die zivilgesellschaft muss dauerhaft
gefördert werden vielen dank
nächster redner für die fdp fraktion dr
thorsten liebt
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin verehrte
kollegin kollegin sie bevor ministerin
feser herr kollege da krieg ich kann sie
beruhigen um den haushaltspolitischen
kompass der fdp fraktion müssen sich gar
keine sorgen machen sie werden sind drei
wochen sehen bei der vorlage des
haushalts für 2023 keine angst und weil
sie das thema des bevölkerungsschutzes
und es der katastrophenhilfe
angesprochen haben nur einen hinweis von
meiner seite wir setzen das jetzt in der
koalition um was sie im vergangenen jahr
nur angekündigt haben deswegen brauchen
wir hier keine belehrung und kolleginnen
kollegen
die hier heute vorliegende fassung des
einzelplan sex zeigt wie die koalition
in zeiten von krisen handlungsfähigkeit
beweis und schwerpunkte setzt es ist in
den haushaltsberatungen einzelner noch
mal gelungen gerade den bereichen
digitalisierung bevölkerungsschutz und
katastrophenhilfe noch einmal deutlich
nach zu schärfen besonders hervorheben
möchte ich in dem bereich aber auch die
umfassenden maßnahmen zur stärkung von
cyber sicherheit und resilienz und zur
beschleunigung von wald verwaltungs
digitalisierung zwar dringend nötig dort
weiterzumachen beispielsweise mit dem
aufbau des zentrums für digitale
souveränität der öffentlichen verwaltung
gelingt endlich ein erheblicher sprung
zu mehr digitaler souveränität in diesem
land die zusätzlichen 37,5 und insgesamt
über 50 millionen euro investieren wir
da massiv in die zukunft dieses landes
der souveräne arbeitsplatz das
wesentliche kern kernprojekt in diesem
bereich setzt auch open source und
leistet damit einen beitrag zu echter
nationaler souveränität in dem bereich
und es macht es durch das offene modell
durch den offenen ansatz auch
transparent und sorgt damit gleichzeitig
auch noch für eine erhöhte sicherheit
der systeme damit wird ein ganz
wichtiges vorhaben des
koalitionsvertrages gleich im ersten
haushalts umgesetzt
die potenziale von daten endlich
umfassend zu heben und dazu ein echtes
daten gesetz für rechtssicherheit bei
der datennutzung zu schaffen dass es uns
als koalition ein zentrales anliegen und
dazu braucht es klar viel mehr als einen
bloßen quantensprung damit deutschland
endlich in die weltspitze der daten
ökonomie vor stehst das ist nicht neu
land liebe kolleginnen kollegen das
zukunftsland und sehen wir zu dass wir
endlich in der zukunft ankommen es wird
allerhöchste zeit
wir leiten den strukturellen umbau der
sicherheitsarchitektur ein und machen
das bundesamt für sicherheit und
informationstechnik endlich unabhängig
damit kommen wir einen weiteren schritt
vorwärts beim aufbau des bsg als
zentrale stelle im bereich der
it-sicherheit
dazu schutz digitale infrastrukturen ist
eine der zentralen
sicherheitspolitischen herausforderungen
unserer zeit auch deswegen habe einen
erheblichen schritt noch mal nach vorne
gemacht im rahmen der haushaltsberatung
wir können cyber sicherheit stärken bei
kritischen infrastrukturen beim thw ist
das gelungen bei den maltesern der die
notwendigkeit von cyber sicherheit geht
natürlich weit über den karren der
inneren sicherheit hinaus da haben wir
geliefert liebe kolleginnen kollegen
ein paar abschließende worte zu sport
ministerin hat es angesprochen während
der korona zeit ist schulunterricht
ausgefallen angebote von sportvereinen
wurden wurden eingestellt deswegen ist
wichtig dass wir dieses programm
auflegen ich sage das bewusst aus
aktuellem anlass wenn ich die vielen
schülerinnen und schüler hier im saal
sehe vor zwei tagen kam eine studie die
deutlich gemacht hat es ist viel weniger
bewegung passiert im panini zeiten des
weges ist ein ganz zentrales signal für
den sport für den breitensport und auch
für die gesundheit dort nach vorne zu
kommen
braucht aber auch vorbilder deswegen ist
uns auch die förderung des spitzensport
ist ein zentrales anliegen mehr athleten
können bei internationalen wettbewerben
teilnehmen das haben wir erreicht wir
unterstützen zusätzlich die special
olympics world gehen uns hier in berlin
und das bekannte institut eine unserer
medaillen spielen das fes hier in berlin
können wir mit zusätzlichen mitteln
versorgen eine echte deutsche
erfolgsgeschichte sorgen wir dafür dass
es so bleibt wir haben jedenfalls vor
als koalition auch die innenpolitik zu
einer echten erfolgsgeschichte zu machen
dafür stehen wir an vielen dank
thorsten liebhabers außen der
fdp-fraktion nebenbei stellvertretender
nicht nebenbei aber auch wichtig zu
sagen stellvertretender vorsitzender im
rechtsausschuss des bundestages nächster
redner jetzt in dieser debatte zum etat
des bundesinnenministeriums
alexander throm der innenpolitische
sprecher der unionsfraktion der die
kolleginnen kollegen
wir leben in einer krisengeschüttelten
zeit mit großen herausforderungen eine
zeit in der sich unsere bürgerinnen und
bürger vor allem die nach klaren
verlässlichen kurs ihrer regierung sehen
aber fehlanzeige
das was wir bislang von ihnen gehört
haben waren viele teils
widersprüchlichen frau ministerin
ankündigungen aber keinerlei gesetze und
das schafft weder eine gefühlte
sicherheit und noch weniger eine
tatsächliche sich
wenn dazu
wäre es notwendig dass sie erst mal ihr
haus bestellen viele positionen haben
sie geräumt es ist in ordnung nach einem
regierungswechsel auch die des beamteten
staatssekretärs für migration diese
position ist seit sechs monaten
unbesetzten dagegen haben sie sich
gleich drei beamtete staatssekretäre
gegönnt in einer antwort von dieser
woche auf eine abgaben abfrage von mir
deshalb es denn mehr staatssekretäre
brauche haben sie gesagt die zahl der
staatssekretäre spiegele das sehr große
aufgaben portfolio aufgrund der
zentralen vorhaben der neuen
bundesregierung wieder ministerin das
passt nicht der zuständigkeitsbereich
des innenministeriums ist geschrumpft
und nicht gestiegen das einzige was ich
mir erklären kann ist dass diese drei
staatssekretäre ihnen den rücken frei
halten sollen damit sie den wahlkampf in
hessen bestreiten wenn aber
frauen es darin
das innenministerium ist keine
wahlkampfzentrale und es ist in der tat
zu wichtig als dass ist eine freizeit
ministerin auf abruf verfahren
denn wir müssen beispielsweise
den kampf gegen den kindesmissbrauch
noch energischer führen und das nicht
erst seit dem bekanntwerden der
widerwärtigen taten energie diese woche
und da haben sie zunächst frau
ministerin die vorschläge der
eu-kommission zur zeitkontrolle begrüßt
nach kritik von fdp und grünen sind sie
zurück gerudert was ist aber tatsächlich
braucht das sind gesetzliche
mindestspeicherfristen von mindestens
sechs monaten und ja es braucht den
zugriff auf die ip-adressen
justizminister buschmann will uns
weismachen dass das sogenannte
quick-freeze-verfahren
ausreicht es ist keine alternativen weil
die verbindungsdaten sind bereits
gelöscht wenn sie den zugriff machen
wollen das heißt die täter entkommen
noch schlimmer wir können die opfer
nicht schützen deswegen begrüße ich
außerordentlich dass sie gestern
erstmals zu erkennen gegeben haben dass
sie auch auf die ip adressen zugreifen
wollen war abend haben sie das heute
morgen in ihrer regel nicht nochmals
wiederholen und will es ihnen sagt mit
weil sie in diesem punkt keine
zustimmung kein applaus von fdp und
grünen bekommen hat deswegen hoffe ich
sehr dass sie auch in diesem punkt nicht
wieder zurückrudern müssen weil wir
müssen hier einen besseren schutz und
bessere ermittlungsmöglichkeiten bei
diesem widerwärtigen taten von
kindesmissbrauch schaffen
und liebe kollegen kollegen ja so schön
gesagt worden da müssen natürlich auch
bei der cyber sicherheit besser werden
das nicht erst seit dem 24
danach ist es umso dringender aber auch
hier widersprüchliches von ihnen erst
haben sie im kampf gegen cyberattacken
die möglichkeit sogenannte heck becks
ins spiel gebracht nach kritik von fdp
und grünen haben sie auch dies wieder
relativiert und gemerkt dass im
koalitionsvertrag entsprechende heck
becks ausgeschlossen sind was gilt denn
nun und auch jetzt diese woche wiederum
haben sie vorgeschlagen dass man hier
mehr cyber sicherheit machen müsste der
krieg dauert seit 100 tagen was haben
sie hier konkret getan jedenfalls in den
haushaltsansätzen in diesem
haushaltsansatz auch im ergänzungs
haushalt findet sich hierzu nichts neues
und auch im bevölkerungsschutz haben sie
für unruhe gesorgt erst haben sie die
bevölkerung aufgefordert noto räte zu
beschaffen anzulegen keine zwei wochen
später haben sie die vorschläge und
empfehlungen ihres eigenen amtes sogar
das großen schutz in frage gestellt das
sorgt für verunsicherung und nicht für
tatsächliche sicherheit
ja wir brauchen mehr geld für den
katastrophen und zivilschutz aber wo
bleibt da ein kräftiger vorschlag aus
ihrem haus für diesen haushalt auch
nicht im ergänzungs haushalt 77
millionen euro wir haben nicht erwartet
dass sie gleich die zehn milliarden auf
einmal in den haushalt einstellen aber
0,77 prozent dessen was erforderlich ist
ist eindeutig zu wenig
und sie herr kollege kritisch waren da
die längste zeit mit dabei
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
und auch in der migrationspolitik können
wir leider nur ein irrlichtern
feststellen erst die ankündigung einer
koalition der willigen unter deutscher
führung dann kritik diesmal nicht mit
den fdp und grünen sondern aus der
gesellschaft und in den medien dann ein
zurückrudern das sei ja gar kein eigener
vorschlag soll man würde sich nur der
initiative des französischen präsidenten
anschließen dann bei dem thema sekundär
migration völlige untätigkeit etwa
43.000 menschen die in griechenland
bereits anerkannt sind als
schutzberechtigte kommen nach
deutschland beantragen hier erneut asyl
ich an sechs monaten keine einzige
äußerung und noch wenige tag weniger
taten in diesem thema festgestellt laut
koalitionsvertrag soll es eine
rückführung offensive geben sechs monate
nichts passiert arbeitsverweigerung noch
nicht bei den bevollmächtigten für
migrations abkommen bekommen sehen weil
sie sich wieder frau bergung streiten
wenn diese allerdings nicht bei ihnen im
ministerium angesiedelt ist dann
offenbart sich die rückführung des
offensive als das hat sie diesen
wirklich eine luftnummer herzlichen dank
alexander throm badass der neben
politische sprecher der unions-fraktion
naturgemäß möchte man fast sagen nicht
einverstanden mit vielen punkten die wie
bundesinnenministerium hier vor einigen
minuten vorgetragen hat zu ihrem etat
und zu ihren politischen vorhaben ihn in
diesem jahr der nächste redner ist
martin gerster spd fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin wirte
kolleginnen und kollegen sehr geehrte
frau ministerin nancy faeser im
gegensatz zur darstellung des kollegen
rom will ich sagen die wehrhaftigkeit
der demokratie die widerstandsfähigkeit
unserer gesellschaft im inneren wird mit
diesem haushalt gestärkt und zwar
spürbar nachhaltig und ganz im sinne der
zeitenwende in dem wir prävention
politische bildung den schutz unserer
bevölkerung und den zusammenhalt unserer
gesellschaft in den mittelpunkt der
politik rücken das ist die wahrheit und
das sondervermögen war dass wir auch in
diesen wochen diskutieren war notwendig
und ist notwendig für die äußere
sicherheit für die landes- und
bündnisverteidigung
im einzelplan 06 wird die zeit wenn die
im inneren unseres landes deutlich
sichtbar einige beispiele 1000 stellen
für die bundespolizei waren bereits im
regierungsentwurf von nancy faeser drin
jetzt ermöglichen wir der bundespolizei
in den kommenden jahren weitere 2000
planstellen aus zu bringen so dass wir
schon in diesem jahr die anwärterinnen
und anwärter dafür einstellen können das
bundeskriminalamt erhält 107 stellen
mehr außerdem zehn millionen euro aus
dem ergänzungs haushalt für polizeiliche
ausbildung und ausstattungshilfe in der
ukraine auch dass es zeitenwende das bka
kann ist international eine hohe
reputation in der forensik zur
untersuchung und beweisaufnahme von
kriegsverbrechen hier unterstützen wir
die ukraine
mit gräueltaten an zivilisten und
zivilisten aufgeklärt und täter zur
verantwortung gezogen werden können ich
glaube das ist auch richtig und
notwendig
es zeigt bei nancy faeser und bei uns in
der ampel ist sicherheit in guten händen
und das gilt auch für bevölkerungs und
katastrophenschutz sowie zivilschutz der
ergänzungs haushalt allein sieht
investitionen von über 50 millionen euro
vor und da kann man sich über den
änderungsantrag der union ehrlich gesagt
nur wundern denn hier wird heute ja
beantragt dass wir für die
nachrichten-app nina und wahn systeme
wie über cell broadcast 19 millionen
euro zusätzlich zur verfügung stellen
sollen entschuldigung das ist im
ergänzungs haushalt schon drin das ist
schon beschlossen wir haben nämlich 420
millionen euro für eine moderne waren
infrastruktur einen weiterentwickelten
katastrophenschutz waren app system li
na mit sms warnungen und einer digitalen
syrien schnittstelle drin mit verweis
auf die entsprechenden haushaltstitel
der antrag lieber andré berg ist also
obsolet also das papier bitte schön
schnell wieder einrollen sonst wird es
nämlich ganz schön peinlich an dieser
stelle
beim technischen hilfswerk gibt es
unglaublich gute resonanz auf die
beschlüsse von uns in der
bereinigungssitzung
aufgrund unserer anträge die wir als
ampel
vorgebracht haben es gibt zwei so
zusätzliche logistik zentren zur
krisenvorsorge zehn millionen euro zur
anschaffung von sogenannten unimog hoch
geländegängigen fahrzeugen eine halbe
million euro für die cyber hilfe die
durch das thw in zukunft geleistet
werden soll und im übrigen ganz
besonders viel positive resonanz über
unser liegenschafts programm wir haben
99 millionen euro zusätzlich an mit
titeln bei der bima organisiert damit 30
bis 50 zusätzliche thw unterkünfte
modernisiert werden können gute
rahmenbedingungen für unsere
ehrenamtlichen im thw und darüber hinaus
das ist es was die ehrenamtlichen
brauchen und drückt auch unsere
dankbarkeit aus für das was sie rund um
die uhr in den einsätzen in deutschland
und international leisten
auch im bereich der migration und
integration steht viel mehr geld zur
verfügung das muss man ganz klar sagen
ich verweise auf
zusätzliche gelder 8 millionen euro für
die integration für die
migrationsberatung für erwachsene
zuwanderer
ich freue mich auch dass mit fünf
millionen euro jetzt erste
vorbereitungen für die unabhängige
asylverfahrens beratung getroffen werden
können ein zentrales anliegen von uns in
der ampel und von uns in der spd mit dem
letzten innenminister und mit cdu/csu
wäre dies wahrscheinlich niemals möglich
gewesen das zeigt zeitenwende auch in
anderen politikbereichen und darauf
glaube ich können wir auch ganz schön
stolz einer ampel dass wir das jetzt auf
den weg bringen
wir haben bei der bundeszentrale für
politische bildung jetzt an die marke
100 millionen euro im etat erreicht das
ist absoluter rekord und zeigt dass wir
auch politische bildung setzen dass wir
auf prävention setzen das gilt im
übrigen auch was das thema
antisemitismus anbelangt das ist ja
erschreckend welche entwicklung das
ganze nimmt und es ist gut dass wir hier
zeichen setzen mittel aufwuchs und mehr
stelle damit bei antisemitismus besser
bekämpfen können im übrigen auch sehr
gut wir stärken den sport dazu wird
sabine poschmann für die spd fraktion
noch mal was sagen jedenfalls bin ich
der meinung wir sind gut aufgestellt im
etat des bundesinnenministeriums
möchte mich bedanken bei famila schäfer
und bei torsten lieb insbesondere aber
natürlich auch bei der ministerin nancy
faeser und ihrem ganzen haus für die
hervorragende zusammenarbeit das war
wirklich klasse gute grundlage für die
nächsten jahre in dieser
legislaturperiode was denn in etwa
anbelangt zwischen dank
martin gerster für die spd-fraktion und
vielleicht auch noch ein paar zahlen zu
dem was er zuletzt gesagt hat 20 21 gab
es so viele politisch motivierte
straftaten wie noch nie mehr als 55.000
auch die judenfeindlichen straftaten
haben zugenommen einen höchststand 29
prozent mehr als 20 20 jetzt gottfried
curio der innenpolitische sprecher der
fdp-fraktion eine zeitenwende im
innenressort bleibt aus es bleibt alles
beim alten grenzen auf dem portemonnaie
offen germany last and least migration
hunderttausende durch 70 länder gezogen
werden uns an der grenze als fliegender
aufgenötigt und die fdp will von ihrem
abschiebe beauftragten koalitionsvertrag
schon nichts mehr wissen man hat ja
einen queer beauftragten für anderer
kriminalität 20 21 ein drittel der
tatverdächtigen ausländer in münchen
stuttgart düsseldorf geht die hälfte
aller straftaten auf ihr konto in
frankfurt zwei drittel die lösung der
ampelmann bürgert noch schneller ein und
schon gibt es weniger kriminelle
ausländer die bürger lassen sich aber
nicht für dumm verkaufen frau feser
auf sonst wird die sicherheit
vorsätzlich vernachlässigt von links gab
es letztes jahr mehr politische
gewalttaten als von rechts dramatisch
viel mehr gegen polizeibeamte
islamistische gefährder achtmal mehr als
rechtsextreme islamistische terror
verfahren 40 mal mehr als antwort man
erfindet eine schlagzeile
rechtsextremismus in sicherheitsbehörden
bei anhaltspunkten bei 300 personen von
600.000 ein halbes promille 99,95
prozent waren klien die schlagzeile
bewusste desinformation und wo sind ihre
ansätze gegen kleinkriminalität nancy
faeser hat die prioritäten erkannt sie
zeigt flagge vor ministerium die
regenbogenflagge und eine milliarde für
linke lobbygruppen migrantenvereine zur
angeblichen demokratie förderung
natürlich mit projekt autonomie aber
ohne bekenntnis zur fdp das braucht
niemand meine damen und herren
aber fässer will nicht nur rechtsextreme
netzwerke zerschlagen gehen jeder
innenausschusssitzung verzweifelt
gesucht werden aber nie auftauchen
wollen schon im kindergarten brauche es
demokratieerziehung dass es egal ist wo
eine familie mal hergekommen ist es geht
überhaupt nicht um extremismus
bekämpfung des geht um indoktrination
kritik an der aggressiven
zuwanderungspolitik soll abzug werden
das ziel keine mündigen bürger sondern
links programmierte schlaf schafe das
ist nicht die marke die förderung
sondern behinderung aber damit kennen
sie sich ja aus meinungs- unterdrückung
durch ihr netz zensurgesetz
oppositions unterdrückung hier im haus
durch verwirrung der minderheitenrechte
wer hier das demokratie problem ist das
sind sie
und die ministerin will für ihren
politischen begriff
kampfbegriffe umfeld schon etwa das wort
heimat positiv umdeuten heimat ist für
sie ein negativer begriff o ton es ist
ein offener begriff dass alle menschen
so leben können wie sie möchten man will
also nicht integration einfordern
sondern enthaltung der einheimischen
feser der begriff soll signalisieren
dass wir die gesellschaft zusammenhalten
wollen nein das soll oder nicht er
bedeutet viel mehr den anspruch der
einheimischen bevölkerung auf ein leben
in ihrem land nach gewachsenen
traditionen die menschen um ihre heimat
zu betrügen das wird ihnen nicht gelegen
und der rechtsbruch geht weiter man
belässt migranten nicht in erst an kunst
ländern gibt hunderttausende abgelehnte
nicht abkoppelt entwicklungshilfe nicht
an rücknahme illegaler migranten dafür
darf der steuerzahler seit 20.15 900.000
migranten in hartz4 beköstigen es
bräuchte sach statt geldleistungen für
asylbewerber effektiver abschiebungen
mehr sichere herkunftsländer stattdessen
fordert spd-frau frattini und die grünen
noch mehr anreize für einwanderung in
die sozialsysteme hartz4 sofort für
jeden über die grenzen kommt das wird
unsere ärmeren mitbürger jetzt sicher
freuen so viele wohltaten und 9
milliarden die zur angeblichen flucht
ursachenbekämpfung eine absurde riesen
gießkanne ins ausland das wird unsere
inflations geplagten bürger freuen und
jetzt noch regelmäßig milliarden für die
ukraine wer wollte da noch niedrigere
heizkreise wenn ihnen so das herz
gewärmt wird immer getreu dem regierungs
motto wir kümmern uns um jeden solange
er nicht aus deutschland stammt ich
danke
herr choreo aus der fdp fraktion hält an
seinem thema fest jetzt geht es weiter
in der debatte um den etat mit marcel
emmerich aus der fraktion bündnis 90/die
grünen obmann im ausschuss für inneres
und heimat
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen zunächst mal zu
mal vorredner ich bin neu im deutschen
bundestag und das eine sehr sehr große
ehre hier in diesem redepult zu stehen
an diesem wohnhaus zu reden und das ist
wirklich fürchterlich wie sie mit diesen
redepult umgehen welche ständigen
tierarten die hinaus machen und wie sie
diese er wäre dieses wohnhauses immer
wieder
stellen
hinter uns liegen ganz besondere
haushaltsverhandlungen mit wirklich eine
hoch mit hochmotivierten
regierungsfraktionen mit einer neuen
engagierten minister ministerin und
gleichzeitig aber auch schwierigen und
dynamischen umständen eine pandemie
einem angriffskrieg in europa und einer
fluchtbewegung die uns vor
herausforderungen stellt das sind die
mensa aufgaben für den bund für die
länder die kommunen für die vielen
ehrenamtlichen und auch die
sicherheitskräfte und insbesondere
beiden letzteren gilt unsere
unterstützung und unser dank für ihre
tolle arbeit herzlichen dank
und ja sie sind ein haushaltsdebatte da
geht es um geld aber geld allein macht
nicht glücklich aber es ist dennoch
immer eine gute grundlage um seine
politischen anliegen voranzubringen und
in diesem fall für eine politik die wert
darauf legt freiheit sicherheit und
rechtsstaatlichkeit für alle menschen zu
gewährleisten
mit einem klaren bekenntnis zur
humanitären aufnahme von geflüchteten
der stärkung der demokratie
für einen funktionsfähigen zivil und
katastrophenschutz und herd rom mit
einem evidenzbasierten und grundrechts
orientierten an wer auch rechtsstaatlich
sicherheit so machen wir das bei fragen
konnte verraten haben dass es im kern
bereit wird und wer es nicht erschüttert
und dass es kein generalverdacht gibt
das ist unser anliegen und sie sind da
ganz falsch unterwegs
deswegen stoßen wir im haushalt auch zum
beispiel jetzt die überwachungs
gesamtrechnung an und belegen dass mit
geld wir stärken das bbk und das thw
unter anderem mit geländegängigen
fahrzeugen oder auch unimog genannt wir
sorgen auch für mehr geld für die
unterbringung der geflüchteten und
setzten den starken fokus auf die
it-sicherheit
in den letzten wochen und monaten haben
wir aber auch noch was anderes wieder
sehr deutlich zu spüren bekommen auf sie
eingehen möchte
razzien um die zellen der sogenannten
atomwaffen division combating und knock
out fiftyone auseinanderzunehmen
platzieren in 20 objekten den neuen
bundesländern um die so genannten seiten
patrioten auszuhebeln sie zählten unter
anderem mit anschlägen auf den
gesundheitsminister ab hatten pistolen
kalaschnikow nachtsichtgeräte und vieles
mehr und standen bereit und jeremy er
plante einen rechtsextremistisch
motivierten anschlag auf schülerinnen
und lehrkräfte in dem von ihm besuchten
gymnasium in essen wir sehen die
bedrohung rechtsextremer
gewalt bleibt hochaktuell und an diesen
nachrichten die wir in den letzten
wochen genannt bekommen haben dürfen wir
uns nicht gewöhnen wir dürfen das nicht
hinnehmen wir stellen uns
wir stellen uns recht im netzwerken
entschieden entgegen
und an dieser stelle möchte ich auch den
ermittlungsteams sanken die das aus
ermittelt und aufgedeckt haben das
verdeutlicht ein entschlossenes vorgehen
der sicherheitsbehörden ist von
besonderer bedeutung und deswegen
starten wir diese jetzt auch weiter
personell gut aus und außerdem stärken
die zivilgesellschaft die auch im kampf
gegen rechts so wichtig ist rechter
terror ist die bedrohung für unsere
demokratie der einsatz dagegen hat
oberste priorität für uns das will ich
endlich auch auf den gestrigen dritten
todestag von walter lübcke noch mal dick
und fett unterstreichen
sehr geehrte frau ministerin die haben
einen aktionsplan gegen
rechtsextremismus vorgelegt wir sind
bereit ihn abzuarbeiten gemeinsam
hoffentlich auch mit einem
demokratischen fraktionen hier im haus
wir sind dazu bereit wir wollen loslegen
fangen wir an und diese einsprachen ist
eine gute basis dafür vielen dank
marcel emmerich für die fraktion bündnis
90/die grünen obmann im innenausschuss
des bundestages ihm wird jetzt folgen
andré hahn aus der linkspartei unter
anderem sprecher für den themenbereich
sport aber auch für die geheimdienst
kontrolle und für zivilen
katastrophenschutz und der
katastrophenschutz spielt ja eine
deutlich größere rolle als in früheren
jahren in diesem haushalt als sprecher
der fraktion die linke für zivil- und
katastrophenschutz möchte ich dazu
einige anmerkungen machen die
aufstockungen für das technische
hilfswerk begrüßen wir ausdrücklich das
darf aber nicht darüber hinwegtäuschen
natürlich hinzu dass unser land im fall
von naturkatastrophen pandemien und
größeren schluck bewegung nach wie vor
schlecht aufgestellt ist stadt
zusätzliche 100 milliarden für die
bundeswehr zu verpulvern wäre es gut
wenn wenigstens einen bruchteil dieser
mittel für den zivilen
katastrophenschutz zur verfügung
gestellt würde uns selbst bayerns
innenminister herrmann fordert dafür
zehn milliarden euro
chaos im innenministerium auch beim
katastrophenschutz modul labor 5000 wie
viele gute module sollen denn nun
wirklich neu angeschafft und dauerhaft
finanziert werden keine klaren aussagen
nun zum sport am 27 april war ministerin
feser im sportausschuss auf meine frage
ob es nach ihrem amtsantritt personelle
veränderungen in der abteilung sport
gegeben hat solche vorgesehen sind haben
sie frau ministerin geantwortet zitat
mit der abteilung bin ich sehr zufrieden
ich habe nicht vor sie zu verändern
letzte woche wird den plätzen die
abteilungsleiterin in den vorzeitigen
ruhestand versetzt laut medienberichten
angeblich wegen unüberbrückbarer
differenzen
das sind heute kein wort von ihnen bei
sportstätten und schwimmbädern gibt es
nach wie vor einen bundesweiten
sanierungsstau von mehr als 30
milliarden euro die koalition hat jetzt
dafür lediglich
449 millionen euro bereitgestellt
verteilt auf sechs jahre das ist nicht
mehr als der tropfen auf den heißen
stein wir als linke fordern einen echten
goldenen plan sportstätten an dem sich
der bund in den kommenden zehn jahren
mit jeweils einer milliarde euro
beteiligt und diese position teilen
inzwischen auch der dfb und der deutsche
städtetag
letzter gedanke ich hoffe dass wir uns
alle einig sind dass der sport eine
herausragende bedeutung in unserer
gesellschaft hat deshalb frage ich wo
bleibt der überfällige sport und
bewegung bewegungs gipfel im kanzleramt
den nicht nur der dfb fordert herr
bundeskanzler laden sie endlich dazu ein
der fc bundestag hat in lachen bei
seiner musik und gewählten
parlamentarier turnier geliefert das
innenministerium muss beim haushalt noch
deutlich nachdenken
nächster redner für die fdp-fraktion
platin coole und er ist
stellvertretender fraktionsvorsitzender
frau präsidentin
meine damen und herren heute vor drei
jahren wurde der kasseler
regierungspräsident weiter lücke von
einem rechtsextremisten erschossen und
der kollege emmerich hat gerade daran
erinnert und zu recht darauf aufmerksam
gemacht dass man in einer
haushaltspolitischen debatte über die
prioritäten der bundesregierung und der
ampel mehrheit sprechen muss und eine
der prioritäten ist die bekämpfung des
rechtsextremismus liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen das ist der richtige ansatz
dieser neuen ampel mehrheit und dieser
bundesregierung es ist aber vor allen
dingen mehr als ein lippenbekenntnis es
muss verbunden sein mit konkreten
maßnahmen wir sind schon viele
angesprochen worden ich will mich aber
hier auf einer beschränkten die mir
besonders am herzen liegt und das ist
die verteidigung und der schutz der
ehrenamtlich tätigen und der
kommunalpolitikerinnen und
kommunalpolitiker die bespuckt werden
die bepöbelt werden die an ihren privat
anschriften belagert werden das muss
aufhören sonst werden wir keine leute
mehr finden die sich ehrenamtlich bei
unserer gesellschaft engagieren und es
ist gut und richtig dass wir gerade auch
in diesem bereich die sensibilität
unserer sicherheitsbehörden erhöhen wenn
wir über die prioritäten der
bundesregierung und der
bundestagsmehrheit sprechen dann geht es
auch um die verteidigung der
bürgerrechte und gerade im digitalen
raum und deswegen bin ich ihnen liebe
frau bundesministerin besonders dankbar
dass sie sich beim thema chat kontrolle
so klar an die seite des bundes
justizministers und das digital
ministers gestellt haben denn wir müssen
uns einmal klar machen was das bedeuten
würde denn anlasslos und flächendeckend
jede private kommunikation gescannt
würde diese pläne auf der ebene der
europäischen union während das ende
jeder vertraulichen kommunikation
während das ende der privatsphäre
während das ende der informationellen
selbstbestimmung deswegen ist es gut
dass die bundesrepublik deutschland das
nicht mitmachen wird lieber populisten
minister und es ist doch weltfremd und
naiv zu glauben dass dieses instrument
nur für kindesmissbrauchs bekämpfung
eingesetzt würde sie sind doch die
ersten von der union die beginnen werden
den einsatz dieses instruments für
weitere kriminalitätsformen zu fordern
das geht doch schon los und genau
deswegen darf man diese tür nicht
aufmachen und ich sage ihnen noch was
das gleiche gilt das gleiche gilt für
die vorratsdatenspeicherung
wir haben eine situation in deutschland
in der nach vielen vielen jahren der
verantwortung der union im bereich der
innenpolitik keine
vorratsdatenspeicherung stattfindet und
damit die daten auch nicht genutzt
werden können wissen sie woran das liegt
das liegt daran dass schwarze sheriffs
von der union immer und immer wieder mit
dem kopf vor die selbe wand laufen
nämlich europäische und deutsche
gerichte wir haben also keine
möglichkeit diese daten zu nutzen und
diese bundesregierung diese ampel
mehrheit wird eine
verantwortungsbewusste möglichkeit
einführen können sich darauf verlassen
daten zu nutzen die bürgerrechte zu
schützen und damit dazu beizutragen dass
ein ganz widerliches verbrechen das
widerlichste straftaten bekämpft werden
und das ist der kindesmissbrauch es gibt
glaube ich eine nachfrage weg von
kollektor lassen sie wirklich bist sehr
freuen ja noch sehr
coole dass sie die nachfrage zu lassen
wir sind uns einig im kampf gegen
kindesmissbrauch 'nen wollen das auch so
effektiv wie möglich machen und sie
haben es gerade auch ausgeführt ist
sicherlich das urteil des vgh von ende
april kann zu einem irischen fall gerade
zum thema vorratsdatenspeicherung oder a
nochmals und arbeiten nun mehr explizit
auch ausnahmen zugelassen hat von dem
grundsätzlichen verbot oder der
begrenzung
insbesondere auch was das thema nutzung
registrierung und aus lesung von
ip-adressen anbelangt würden sicherlich
auch bekannt dass alle experten die
damit zu tun haben insbesondere
bka-präsident münch genau diese
möglichkeit fordert und zwar mindestens
rückwirkend auf sechs monate die frau
innenministerin hat gestern ebenfalls
die nutzung dieser ip adressen
richtigerweise und dankenswerter weise
gefordert meine frage einziehen die fdp
sind sie mit diesem vorschlag der
nutzung der ip adressen auch rückwirkend
bis zu sechs monaten einverstanden nein
damit sind wir nicht einverstanden
lieber kollege throne und ich will ihnen
ganz deutlich sagen was der unterschied
zwischen ihnen und uns ist der
unterschied ist dass sie
verfassungswidrige gesetze machen um
dann darauf warten und dann darauf
warten dass das bundesverfassungsgericht
oder der genau aufschreiben und
ausbuchstabiert was sie dürfen und was
sie nicht wir dürfen um dann
anschließend um dann anschließend genau
das aus dem gerichtsurteil abzuschreiben
und ins gesetz zu schreiben so arbeiten
sie der unterschied ist dass die neue
ampel mehrheit und insbesondere die fdp
so arbeitet dass sie sich vorher
überlegt was sind eigentlich gerne hätte
und was eigentlich was bringen würde und
auch ein parlamentarisches selbstbewusst
crime oder ein parlamentarisches
selbstverständnis hat dass der
gesetzgeber hier im deutschen bundestag
sitzt und bei allem respekt nicht in
karlsruhe denn dort findet anschließend
eine kontrolle der gesetze stadt und
nicht vorher deswegen wird diese
bundesregierung deswegen wird diese
bundestagsmehrheit mehr möglichkeiten
schaffen als sie über jahre gelassen
haben weil sie immer und immer wieder
den gleichen fehler gemacht haben und
ich bin sehr optimistisch dass damit die
zahl der täter die wirklich was machen
die hier vor gericht bringen werden
steigen wird und darauf können sie sich
verlassen lieber herr kollege trogen
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
ich will gerne diese gelegenheit aber
auch nutzen um neben dem thema
bürgerrechte um neben dem thema
krisenbewältigung extremismus
bewältigung auch etwas anzusprechen was
im bereich der innenpolitik nicht unter
den tisch fallen darf und das sind
strukturelle reformen ich habe nämlich
das gefühl dass unser
bundesinnenministerium einem wirklich
guten job macht wenn es darum geht
operative fragen zu klären und mit dem
operativen tagesgeschäft klar zu kommen
das ist ja auch völlig klar wenn man
sich den bundeshaushalt anschaut im
bereich des innenministeriums dann ist
dieses haus besonders geprägt durch
operative tätigkeiten gerade im bereich
der bundespolizei aber die innenpolitik
sie braucht auch strukturelle reformen
wir werden über das thema digitale
verwaltung noch sprechen wir müssen über
das thema cyber abwehr sprechen und über
das thema zivilschutz und liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen wir müssen vor
allen dingen sprechen über das thema der
zuwanderung in den arbeitsmarkt dieses
thema darf nicht immer wieder der krisen
rhetorik und der krisenbewältigung in
unserem land zum opfer fallen wir haben
es wegen kuroda nicht hingekriegt wir
haben's nicht hingekriegt war die union
hat ihren lebenslügen in puncto
einwanderungsgesetz nicht klar gekommen
ist wir haben jetzt das thema ukraine
was wir bewältigen müssen aber wir lust
sein erst auf die kette kriegen zu
beginn dieser legislaturperiode einen
paradigmenwechsel in der
einwanderungspolitik hinzubekommen mit
einem wettbewerbsfähigen
einwanderungsgesetz mit einem
punktesystem und auch mit einer
situation wo wir in den hunderten und
tausenden gesprächen die wir jeden tag
mit arbeitgebern führen die sagen mir
fehlen hier fachkräfte bringt sie uns
endlich sagen können wir haben es
geschafft und wir haben ein einfaches
gesetz für deutschland auf den weg
gebracht diese struktur reformen sie
müssen auch sein und die fdp macht gerne
mit vielen dank
kurz denn die coole stellvertretender
vorsitzender der fdp-fraktion hatte in
seiner rede noch mal auf einen die sense
hingewiesen
der basiert auf den plänen der
eu-kommission nämlich die pflicht die
geplante pflicht für google facebook und
andere ihre seiten nach missbrauchs-
fotos und videos zu durchsuchen da ist
von der sogenannten chat kontrolle die
rede und die ist nach wie vor umstritten
könnte auch in der koalition zu einer
deutlichen konflikten noch führend fritz
güntzler ist am pult ob man im
sportausschuss und das ganze für die
unionsfraktion habe ich im hause alle
einig hat eine besondere
gesellschaftliche bedeutung das betrifft
sowohl die nicht organisierten sport
aber auch den organisierten sport in
deutschland über 27 millionen menschen
treiben in fast 90.000 vereinen sport
dies ist alles nur möglich weil es ein
großartiges ehrenamtliches engagement
von fast neun millionen menschen gibt
die weit über 500 millionen stunden
arbeitsleistung einbringen und ich finde
diese menschen können wir heute morgen
mal danken
der sport ist auch mehr als
gesundheitsforum er leite leistet einen
wichtigen beitrag zum gesellschaftlichen
zusammenhalt zur integration zur
inklusion zur demokratie förderung zur
bildungsarbeit aber insbesondere auch
bei der kinder- und jugendarbeit
erschafft verbindungen vermittelt
wichtige werte wie respekt teamgeist
fairplay die wir auch teilweise hier
alle walten lassen sollten deshalb
braucht der sport unsere gemeinsame
unterstützung und ich weise darauf hin
gerne darauf hin dass wir in der großen
koalition in der letzten
legislaturperiode da einiges geleistet
haben der sport etat ist von
162 millionen euro auf fast 500
millionen euro angewachsen darunter auch
zwei millionen corona hilfen aber der
eine sportförderung aufruf sind über 70
prozent und ich finde da können wir
horst seehofer noch mal ganz herzlich
danken dass er das nach vorne gebracht
hat
und wir sind uns auch einig dass die
sportvereine besonders in der kroner
zeit gelitten haben sportveranstaltungen
waren nicht mehr möglich der
trainingsbetrieb musste teilweise
eingestellt werden die sportvereine
haben mitglieder verloren
unterschiedlicher art bei den kleinen
vereinen sind es weniger als bei den
großen vereinen du musst es richtig die
bundesinnenministerium hat ja darauf
hingewiesen dass ist jetzt ein projekt
neustart nach corona geben sollen ich
finde es aber schon bewundernswert in
anführungsstrichen dass es in dem
entwurf der bundesregierung dafür nichts
enthalten war sondern das was der
haushaltsausschuss war der 25 millionen
euro
stellt hat dadurch ungefähr 270 euro pro
verein da ist also noch ein bisschen
luft nach oben also wir finden es
grundsätzlich richtig peinlich finde ich
aber schon dass der haushaltsausschuss
das mit einem sperrvermerk versehen muss
weil derzeit nach sieben monaten immer
noch kein konzept dieser bundesregierung
vorliegt und frau ministerin hier müssen
sie auch mal handeln
leider zieht sich das wie ein roter
faden auch durch die sportpolitik das
was ich vorhin auch schon zur
sicherheitspolitik hier hören durfte
dass sie vieles ankündigen aber nicht
handeln sie sprechen im
koalitionsvertrag der immerhin eine
halbe seite für den sport darüber hat
von einem entwicklungsplan sport der
entwickelt werden muss fehlanzeige auf
unsere nachfrage im sportausschuss es
gibt derzeit gar nichts in diesem punkt
der dsp der deutsche olympische
sportbund hat jetzt vorschläge
vorbereitet und vorgelegt damit man
überhaupt in die diskussion kommen liebe
frau feser bevor sie personal entlassen
sollen sie über einmal an inhalte gehen
und über inhalte nachdenken damit sie
tatsächlich dinge die sie im
koalitionsvertrag vereinbart haben auch
umsetzen wir können auch weitergehen zur
mittelvergabe beim spitzensport sie
haben geschrieben in den
koalitionsvertrag sie wollen eine
unabhängige instanz schaffen zur
mittelvergabe kein mensch weiß derzeit
was diese instanz sein soll der dfb weiß
es nicht die beteiligten wissen es nicht
wir haben eine förder kommission derzeit
vom bundesinnenministerium gemeinsam mit
dem dmsb die das gut macht sie wollen
die neue instanz schaffen sagen aber gar
nicht wie und wieder zeigt sich sie
handeln nicht sie kündigen nur an
kollege hahn hat es angesprochen auf den
sieger ausbau und sanierung von
sportstätten und sie schreiben im
koalitionsvertrag nicht nur für
kommunale sportstätten sondern auch für
vereinseigenen sportstätten da kommt
jetzt gerade mal über bis zum jahr 2027
476 millionen aus da haben wir uns in
der großen koalition schon mehr gemacht
meine wir haben 600 millionen dritten in
einem jahr da geht mehr und für die
vereinseigenen sportanlagen haben sie
wieder keine lösung gefasst auch da sie
waren sie nicht also im ganzen
zusammengefasst es wäre noch mehr punkte
zu nennen wo sie nicht handeln nehmen
sie die aufgabe ernst nehmen sie den
sport ernst die menschen die eben dem
sport tätigkeit haben es verdient dass
sie ernst genommen werden sie brauchen
wertschätzung und nicht nur
ankündigungen herzlichen dank
nächster redner für die spd-fraktion die
akquise der
krise ist einer der stellvertretenden
fraktionsvorsitzenden
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin
kolleginnen und kollegen es gibt ja das
phänomen in debatten und reden dass man
sonntagsreden hält das man lobt dass man
das ehrenamt lob das man applaus
bekommen möchte und das lieber fritz
güntzler das war nicht gut und ich habe
gerade auch geklatscht was ich mir noch
nicht ganz erklären kann und wir haben
wir die klare fokussierung auf den sport
ist wieso der kollege berghegger im
haushaltsausschuss 7 kürzungsanträge für
den sportbereich eingereicht das passt
aus meiner sicht nicht ganz zusammen und
da hätte man schon ehrlich sein müssen
die prioritätensetzung für den sport war
wohl bei der union nicht ganz so
ausgeprägt ist die kommunikation
zwischen raushauen politiker bei ihnen
anregungen die ganze waren in der
ampelkoalition setzen wir gemeinsam mit
bundesinnenministerium nancy faeser
einen klaren schwerpunkt auf die innere
sicherheit weil wir als ampelkoalition
einen umfassenderen begriff von innerer
sicherheit haben innere sicherheit heißt
für uns nicht strafverschärfungen allein
im strafgesetzbuch sondern genau da
hinzuschauen und zu fragen wie können
wir kriminalität verhindern wie können
wir sicherheit vorbeugend erhöhen für
die bürgerinnen und bürgern in diesem
land und das ist der schwerpunkt den wir
in diesem haushalt setzen der sich im
haushalt wiederfinden und ist der größte
haushaltsetat im innenbereich den wir
jemals gehabt haben und da bin ich in
haushälterin und haushälter der
koalitionsfraktionen sehr dankbar in
westfalen würden wir sagen das habt ihr
ganz ordentlich gemacht vielen dank
dafür
es ist angesprochen worden die stärkung
des technischen hilfswerks setzen sich
fort die sind richtig und die
herausforderungen sind da das haben die
flutkatastrophe im aartal gezeigt dass
haben aber auch gerade erst die tornados
in paderborn und lippstadt gezeigt wie
wichtig es ist auch aufgrund der
klimatischen veränderungen hier
voranzugehen und ich bin der thw
helfervereinigung dem präsidium martin
gerster und andrea lindholz sehr dankbar
dass sie in einer pressemitteilung das
was die ampel koalition hier gemacht hat
ausdrücklich loben dass es gut fürs thw
und gut für die katastrophenhilfe bei
uns im land
ausdrücklich hervorheben will ich auch
die stärkungen der bundespolizei ist es
angesprochen worden und wir wollen
darüber hinaus mit einer klaren
prioritätensetzung auch die
arbeitsbedingungen für die
bundespolizeibeamten und polizeibeamten
voranbringen durch eine bundespolizei
gesetzt was gerade bei den unterkünften
bei den liegenschaften für die
polizeibeamtinnen und -beamten richtige
weichenstellungen auf den weg bringen
wird aber sind wir ehrlich es gehört
genauso dazu die ruhegehalts fähigkeit
der polizei zulage auf den weg zu
bringen hier haben wir uns als
ampelkoalition zu entschlossen das
werden wir auch den weg bringen hier hat
das innenministerium früher blockiert
ich bin dankbar dass das jetzt nicht
mehr passiert dass wir das voranbringen
die gdp als die gewerkschaft der polizei
hat das aus wirklich auch noch mal
begrüßt und hier werden wir die
entsprechenden vorlagen auch sehr
zeitnah auf den weg bringen
ebenso sitzt das bundesinnenministerium
nennt sich nancy faeser entschuldigung
nancy faeser aber auch die klare und
richtige priorität auf die bekannte
bekämpfung des extremismus und gerade
die größte bedrohung die wir im land
haben die bekämpfung des
rechtsextremismus und ich sage es
nochmal zum ausgangspunkt dass wir
genauso oft prävention setzen darum
werden wir als ampel koalition gemeinsam
bundesinnenministerium
bundesfamilienministerium ein demokratie
fördergesetz auf den weg bringen weil
wir die demokratie in unserem land
stärken müssen weil wir die
demokratischen initiativen die sich
täglich überall dafür einsetzen
unterstützen wollen auskömmlich
finanzieren wollen die demokratie muss
wehrhaft sein dazu braucht sie die
unterstützung und das werden wir jetzt
ampelkoalition zeitnah auf den weg
bringen
ebenso werden wir auf den weg bringen
und das bin ich dankbar dass der kollege
coole das auch noch mal prioritär
angesprochen hat wir werden mit einigen
lebenslügen im bereich migration und
einwanderung aufräumen müssen wir sind
ein einwanderungsland wir brauchen ein
modernes einwanderungsrecht wir brauchen
ein chancen aufenthaltsrecht und den
menschen die lange hier sind die in
kettenduldungen gewesen sind die
perspektiven zu geben auch hier werden
wir vorankommen und dann zum schluss
vielleicht noch eine anmerkung
eine anmerkung an den an den kollegen
trugen das neue stilmittel der cdu csu
bundestagsfraktion zeichnet sich ja den
debatten dadurch aus dass man fragen
stellt das haben wir ja gestern auch
erlebt und sie sind da vielleicht ein
bisschen durcheinander gekommen mit den
staatssekretären wie das jetzt zukünftig
ausgesiedelt ist von daher das
instrument der kleinen anfrage der
fragestellung ist vielleicht gut dass
wir ihnen da sehr schnell aufklärung
geben können über die zusammensetzung
der staatssekretäre da haben sie ein
bisschen was durcheinander gebracht
diesem sinne vielen dank für die
aufmerksamkeit
nächster redner für die afg fraktion
jürgen könig
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte kollegen und vor allem liebe
sportler die regierung hat den sport
haushalt in knapp fünf jahren fast
verdoppelt auf jetzt 3 138 millionen
euro die afg hatte schon 20 18 gefordert
bis zum jahr 2022 den sport mit jährlich
340 millionen euro zu fördern
herzlichen glückwunsch frau ministerin
herzlichen glückwunsch lieber
ampelkoalitionen sie haben unseren
vorschlag zu 99,4 prozent umgesetzt so
was wenn man eine punktlandung
frau ministerin sie waren haben 27 april
bei uns im sportausschuss viele ihrer
damals da gelegten vorhaben im sport
hätten auch von a nach b kommen können
beziehungsweise sind schon seit 2008
zehn in unseren sport politischen thesen
formuliert ein paar beispiele
sie nennen es integration des
vereinssports mit den schulen und
ganztagsschulen wir nennen es bessere
kooperation von schule und sportverein
und meinen beide dasselbe die
talentsichtung und talentförderung durch
patenschaften zwischen schulen und
sportvereinen auszubauen nächstes
beispiel wir wollen gemeinsam die
ausrichtung von sportgroßveranstaltungen
mit dem ziel dass in deutschland wieder
olympische spiele stattfinden die
special olympics 20 23 fußballer eben
2024 universiade 2025 in deutschland
sind dafür meilensteine
winter 20 30 in münchen sollte das ziel
sein denn eigentlich war münchens und 20
22 dran dass wir wäre auch dreimal
besser gewesen als diese polit
propaganda show in peking die
sportpolitik geht zurzeit in die
richtige richtung erhöhen sie weiter den
gesellschaftlichen stellenwert des
breiten wie auch des spitzensports aber
kollege günzler hat es angesprochen wir
werden ganz genau schauen ob und wie sie
ihre vorhaben auch wirklich umsetzen
hätten sie den einen oder anderen von
unseren sieben anträgen zum haushalt
aufgenommen irgendwie aufgenommen ja
dann wäre der sport haushalt in einer
einzelabstimmung eventuell sogar
zustimmungsfähig gewesen sport frei und
vielen dank für ihre aufmerksamkeit
[Applaus]
nächste rednerin für die fraktion
bündnis 90/die grünen tina winkelmann
frau präsidentin frau ministerin
kolleginnen und kollegen sportlerinnen
und sportler liebi ehrenamtliche
haushalt heißt nachverhandlungen und
langen nächten zahlen zu präsentieren
und damit unsere gesellschaft antworten
zu geben ich möchte jetzt nicht diese
imposanten zahlen einzelnen präsentieren
sondern eben auch zeigen was wir damit
tun da kommt jetzt der sport ins spiel
sport ist emotion ist leidenschaft
freude und trauer und ist hingabe und
viel folgt es ist der spitzensport der
idole hervorbringt und diese idole
bringen die breite in bewegung da
durchkommen menschen nicht nur zum sport
sondern der sport bekommt eine tragende
rolle für das gesellschaftliche
zusammenleben sport vermittelt
demokratische werte
für uns heißt sportpolitik sich aktiv
für gleichstellung einzusetzen inklusion
leben den kampf gegen rechtsextremismus
und rassismus aufzubauen aufzunehmen
sport integriert auf allen ebenen sport
bringt uns zusammen er eint uns
unsere athletinnen athleten sind hier
vorbilder und brauchen unsere klare
unterstützung sie sind nicht nur im
inneren in ihren disziplinen weltklasse
sie sind auch starke persönlichkeiten
mit staaten stimmen athletinnen rechte
müssen deshalb aktiv und unabhängig
gestärkt werden dafür müssen wir ihnen
als politik bestmögliche voraussetzungen
schaffen und mit diesem haushalt gehen
die einen großen schritt in die richtige
richtung
neben
neben dem tischtennisverein vor ort und
dem spitzensport inland haben wir aber
auch den blick auf die dienende pandemie
mit am meisten zurückstecken mussten wir
bringen kinder und jugendliche nach
coruna wieder in die sporthallen und auf
die sportplätze
dafür müssen die sie aber auch den
standard erfüllen dafür braucht es
mittel und diese stellen wir
alle diese aufgaben tragen im sport vor
allem menschen im ehrenamt dafür gebührt
ihnen anerkennung denn die breite basis
im sport wäre überhaupt nicht möglich
ohne all die freiwilligen die ihre
freizeit opfern um menschen für bewegung
und das miteinander zu begeistern
sports muss aber auch angstfrei offen
und ein vorbild sein gegen jegliche art
der gewalt und diskriminierung
und hier ist in den letzten jahrzehnten
zu wenig passiert
sexualisierte gewalt im sport ist ein
immenses problem von der breite bis in
die spitze und das muss deutlich
angegangen werden und mit uns wird es
das auch
mit einem unabhängigen zentrum für sex
bord schaffen wir eine instanz die den
kampf gegen gewalt im sport aufnimmt und
genauso sieht es beim thema doping aus
auch hier bedarf es noch sehr viel mehr
aufklärung und prävention
hand in hand für sauberen und ehrlichen
sport und das geben wir an
das was sport ausmacht was sport dass
spitzensport voranbringt hier gibt es
noch einiges zu tun um diese aufgabe
haben wir uns leidenschaftlich
angenommen und mit einem klaren aufwuchs
der haushaltsmittel im sportbereich
fördern und fordern wir dass regierung
sehr gezielt damit unsere athletinnen
und athleten sich auf ihre leistung
konzentrieren können und wir mitfiebern
können damit sich die nächste generation
top athletin und nicht nur als poster
ins kinderzimmer hängt sondern sich den
traum ab selber verwirklichen kann und
deswegen würde ich jetzt sagen so
schweiß baumann und papa sagen wir haben
was zu tun und wir ziehen das durch
dankeschön
nächster redner für die fdp-fraktion
doktor volker ridder
[Applaus]
präsidentin liebe kolleginnen liebe
kollegen sehr geehrte zuschauerinnen
zuschauer
wir können mit dem heutigen jetzigen
stand der verwaltungs digitalisierung
nicht zufrieden sein wir alle wissen von
den umsetzungsproblemen beim online
zugangs gesetz wir wissen dass in den
verwaltungen immer noch zuviel gefaxt
gedruckt und reihenweise in papier
ordnern abgeheftet wird wir wissen dass
da in den vergangenen jahren viel zu
wenig passiert wird er passiert ist
schuldig musste eben darüber gucken wir
steuern da jetzt um wie als ampel fang
nämlich mit diesem haushalt damit an
wir haben das zusammen mit dem
bundesfinanzminister geschafft die
haushaltsmittel für die verwaltungs
digitalisierung im vergleich zum vorjahr
um ein drittel also um eine halbe
milliarde 500 millionen euro zu erhöhen
das geld ist das eine aber insgesamt
muss natürlich die öffentliche hand
künftig auch proaktiver sein sie muss
als innovations- und gestaltungskraft
wirken bis in die wirtschaft rhein war
nur in diesem zusammenspiel funktioniert
das ganze
die öffentliche hand ist als größter
auftraggeber it-bereich verpflichtet
diese aufträge so zu vergeben das
staatliche förderung nicht mehr
notwendig sind man kann ja steuern über
diese aufträge und dabei ist durchaus zu
beachten dass diese vergabe lose den
mittelstand berücksichtigen wir haben
aktuelle situation dass die lose so groß
sind dass das nur noch großkonzerne
abarbeiten können und wird gab es
natürlich deutlich abhängig machen von
diesen wir haben hunderttausend personen
tage lose die ausgeschrieben werden
welcher mittelständler sollte was lief
war aber der mittelstand ist das
rückgrat dieses landes in der garant für
den wohlstand
also da müssen wir ran wir müssen die
lose kleiner machen damit das
funktioniert damit wir auch nachhaltig
deutschlands wirtschaftsstandort stärken
ja es 500 millionen findet die so toller
erfolg dazu gehört aber eben auch die
schnelle umsetzung innovativer projekte
an denen jede bürgerin jeder bürger
merkt warum wir als ampel des
fortschritts koalition sind wir setzen
auf die besten lösungen zur umsetzung
in meiner letzten rede hat ihr schon mal
was hatte ich schon etwas erklärt über
die fährte lockt sechs ein neues konzept
mit dem man daten bitte
das ist aber nett freundlich
[Gelächter]
also mit mit diesem free to check zu
schaffen wir es schaffen wir es
tatsächlich eine eine prozess steigerung
von mindestens 30% konservativ gerechnet
es gibt experten die sagen 80 prozent
das heißt wir werden es in dieser
legislatur erleben das analoge amtswege
den meisten bürgerinnen und bürgern
erspart bleiben das ist ein versprechen
das kriegen wir hin
wir investieren als ampel in einem
moderneren digitale rinnen
bürgerfreundlichen staaten schaffen
zugleich ein größeres maß an staatlicher
souveränität und wirtschaftlicher
wettbewerb bei gleichzeitiger
kostensenkung durch den einsatz von
neuen technologien dieser haushalt ist
der erste seit langem der und diese
moderne richtung geht dank an alle die
an diesem haushalt mitgearbeitet haben
heute ist ein guter tag für die
digitalisierung und für deutschland
vielen dank
volker räder und fdp fraktion in der
debatte über den einzelplan sächsinnen
und heimat plus einzelplan 21
bundesdatenschutzbeauftragter und dieser
debatte die drittletzte rednerin ist
mechthilde wittmann aus der
unionsfraktion speziell csu-landesgruppe
und
kollegen mein vorderrad geschlossen mit
dem hinweis heute wäre ein guter tag
durch diesen haushalt da kann ich ihnen
ausdrücklich zustimmen und ich sage
ihnen auch warum frau bundesminister den
phaser hat bei der letzten debatte zu
diesem thema mehr ausdrücklich
beigepflichtet dass es sich um einen
kontinuierlichen haushalt handelt einen
haushalt der kontinuierlich die
haushalte der vergangenen legislatur
fortsetzt und damit bestätigt die
bundesministerin wie auch dieser
haushalt in den wesentlichen punkten die
erfolgreiche innenpolitik die in den
letzten jahren hier geschrieben worden
ist insbesondere von der union aber auch
wenn sie ab und zu eine september
amnesie haben von der spd die sich so
gar nicht mehr erinnern dass sie mit uns
regiert
im alter haben es bestätigt sich auch
ganz einfach in der
kriminalitätsstatistik wo wir
erfreulicherweise ganz große erfolge
seit jahren fortsetzen können und ich
zuversichtlich bin dass sich aufgrund
der hervorragenden arbeit unserer
sicherheitsbehörden
da habe ich heute noch nichts dazu
gehört bei den vielen dankesreden auch
so weiter entwickeln wird wir haben
einen kontinuierlichen rückgang der
straftaten in fast allen bereichen
die aufklärungsquote steigt die
häufigkeit zahlen der straftaten sinkt
und auch die zahl der tatverdächtigen
sind kontinuierlich und dies obwohl wir
bei den nach verfolgungen viel in center
sein können allerdings und auch hier
haben wir gemeinsamkeit bewiesen wir
möchten stoppen den anstieg der
straftaten insbesondere im
rechtsextremistischen bereich ich glaube
hier sind wir uns im hause bis auf
einige sehr sehr wenige vollkommen
einige und diesen weg werden wir uns
gemeinsam gehen und jeder euro ist hier
gut investiert
aber wir haben auch einen anstieg bei
den betrugsdelikten und wir haben einen
anstieg bei den tätlichen angriffen auf
die vollstreckungsbeamte das sind die
die vor ort die sicherheit aller
bürgerinnen und bürger garantieren und
das dürfen wir ebenfalls nicht zulassen
dürfen wir nicht ignorieren
und schließlich nun endlich wurde schon
ausführlich von meinem kollegen
ausgeführt zum zur frage des anstiegs
des exponentiellen anstieg bei der frage
der sexuellen missbrauchs von kindern
aber auch vorbei verbreitung erwerb
besitz und herstellung pornografie
pornografischer schriften insbesondere
kinderpornografische schriften hier um
mehr als 100 prozent
das dürfen wir nicht so stehen lassen
und deswegen ist es mir vollkommen
unbegreiflich dass sie sich in der ampel
allen ernstes auf rückfrage von kollegen
drum leisten den dissenz was wir
einsetzen müssen damit wir hier
eingreifen können und dazu gehört der
zugriff auf die ip-adressen frau
bundesministerin da haben sie unsere
unterstützung leider nicht die von ihren
kollegen mit denen sie arbeiten müssen
aber dazu gehört auch die
vorratsdatenspeicherung und hier gilt
hat einfach zu differenzieren es geht um
den anlassbezogenen
zugriff selbst wenn anlasslos
gespeichert werden konnte damit wir
aufklären können und nicht da stoppen
müssen wir uns die daten fehlen um
endlich diese täter zu fassen wir wollen
den schutz der bürger und nicht der
kriminellen
und lassen sie nicht nach dem gießen auf
meinen kollegen ausführlich geschildert
worden ist zum frage des bevölkerungs
und katastrophen und zivilschutz es hier
nochmal einmal kurz erläutern warum wir
den ergänzungsantrag aufrechterhalten
richtig sie haben hier zugelegt es ist
gut so aber wir wissen auch dass die
mittel die sie uns besondere für die
nina bahn app die so wichtig ist wie nie
zuvor wie wir erfahren haben nicht
ausreichen werden um sie ausreichend
auszustatten nehmen sie doch die gilde
diese geparkt haben stimmen sie dem
antrag zu es tut nicht weh und dafür
können wir hier endlich volle arbeit
leisten das ist wichtig
und der kollege drucker noch das thema
personal schon angesprochen ich darf
noch mal kurz darauf eingehen jawohl wir
sind sehr glücklich dass wir ebenso
kontinuierlich weiter auf beim bei der
bundespolizei aber auch in den
entsprechenden ämtern das ist eine gute
fortsetzung der bisherigen politik und
jetzt wo ich an dieser stelle ich danke
unseren polizei und ordnungskräften
ebenso zu wie der dank an alle anderen
ging dem schließen wir uns an danke ich
den polizei und ordnungskräften die
jeden tag ihren kopf dafür hinhalten
wenn wir das bei uns funktioniert und
ich darf dazu auch gleich noch einmal
beim weitergehen und ihnen eines sagen
wir haben wir rechtsextremismus
gesprochen dass wir uns da richtig
verstehen ja wohl das sind wir ganz an
ihrer seite ich habe kein wort zum thema
linksextremismus gehört es sind die
linksextremistischen gruppen die in
erster linie hier die gewaltbereitschaft
gegen unsere polizei in richtung gegen
die beamten vor ort wir den dienst
verrichten und es ist mir nicht
begreiflich dass sie versuchen wir
offenkundig die augen zuzumachen das
wollen wir nicht und erinnern sie sich
nur an den g20-gipfel in haben dort vom
heutigen bundeskanzler als
hafengeburtstag tituliert tatsächlich
aber unter anderem ein tag des
ungehorsams mit unfassbaren fast 1000
verletzten polizisten
das kann es ja wohl nicht sein im
übrigen haben sie mehr als zehn prozent
davon aus bayern gebraucht um diesen
gipfel überhaupt bewältigen zu können
und ihre gäste überhaupt in sicherheit
bringen zu können
an diesem tag war der tag des bundes
über sams ausgehoben und ich zitiere
ihre partei ihre kollegin ihre
kabinettskollegin städten lemke es ist
absolut legitim für seine anliegen zu
demonstrieren und auch dabei auch formen
des zivilen ungehorsams zu nutzen nein
das ist es nicht weil wir da das ist es
nicht
und wenn sie coole von den schwarzen
schärfste union sprechen dann sage ich
ihnen mal ein assist hat schon ein grund
warum der bundeskanzler diesen g7-gipfel
nach ellmau verlegt hat war kann nämlich
weiß nur dort sind seine gäste so sicher
wie sie es brauchen und wie sie es
bewiesen haben nur dort haben sie best
practice und deswegen sind wir stolz
darauf dass wir diese sicherheit für die
gäste in unserem land liefern können
stehen
mechthilde wittmann aus der
unionsfraktion mit einem rückblick auf
den g7 gibt für den hamburg das ist
jetzt auch schon ein paar jahre her und
bevor in dem einen und anderen e mail
buero sorge entsteht auf der redner
anzahl in dieser debatte und unserer
übertragen keine panik ich habe mich
schlicht und einfach verzählt und wir
bleiben natürlich live drauf über viele
viele stunden noch mit nur einer kleinen
unterbrechung im laufe des späteren
nachmittags also alles in ordnung nur
der kommentator hat sich verzählt 43
regenrinnen kommen noch und ein redner
zum beispiel dunja kreise aus der spd
fraktion jetzt am pult ist
als ehemalige sportpolitische sprecherin
des landtages in niedersachsen bin ich
stolz in dieser ampel koalition jetzt im
bundestag mitwirken zu können die zeigt
dass die ehrenamtlichen in unserer
gesellschaft hier eine besondere
beachtung erfahren sie sind das rückgrat
unserer gesellschaft
wir können deshalb ist es aus dem alltag
meiner kollegin sabine poschmann sein
die zur sportstätten
führungsunterstützung der vereine nach
bewohner zu den großveranstaltungen die
special olympics zu dem programm
integration im sport verehrte damen und
herren berichten wird wir machen einen
großen aufschrei unterstützung der
ehrenamtlichen und hauptamtlichen zivil
und katastrophenschutz zum beispiel aus
dem ergänzungs haushalt 50 millionen
plus für eine moderne statt um
refinanzierung der ausgaben für die
beschaffung im zusammenhang mit den
ausgaben durch den krieg in der ukraine
wir stehen das waren meldesystem digital
auf frau widmann und das 12 steht
einfach schon drin natürlich redundant
aber so dass die endgerät mit der nina
war nicht schnell die bevölkerung
erreicht wird mit dem modularen
wahnsystem mofas und der einführung der
sms planung fast
99 millionen in der ersten tranche für
einen neubau für den thw in einem neubau
programm für die gebäudetechnik damit
sind wir auf dem weg zu einem residenten
zivil und katastrophenschutz der
gewappnet ist für umweltkatastrophen für
internationalen krisen einzige lang hat
das kurven schutz mehr vor allem aber
auch den blick auf die menschen hat
verehrte damen und herren 8 millionen
euro für ein neues zentrum für die
einsatznachsorge um eine bessere
psychosoziale betreuung zu gewährleisten
ist dringend geboten für die
einsatzkräfte in krisensituationen für
unsere ehrenamtler dazu kommt ein großes
paket für digitalisierung und cyber
sicherheit der kritischen infrastruktur
für die kompetenz erweiterung des thws
für die härtung der struktur innerhalb
des malteser hilfsdienstes entwicklung
digitaler lagebilder zu werfen
koordinierung zwischen land bund und
kommunen digitalisierung verehrte damen
und herren zeigt sich im übrigen in dem
gesamten haushalt neben vieler verpasste
aufgaben in den letzten 16 jahren ist
wohl die digitalisierung in unserer
verwaltung im zivilschutz und auf dem
bildungssektor das was am meisten
verschlafen wurde wir wagen fortschritt
wir bringen die digitalisierung der
verwaltung voran davon profitieren die
ehrenamtlichen davon profitieren alle
bürgerinnen und bürger davon profitieren
unternehmen wir haben so haben wir das
zb demo cd booster auf den weg gebracht
bis zum ende des jahres werden wir
deutliche erleichterungen tag spüren 35
wichtige verwaltungsdienstleistungen
werden dann digitalisiert sein es ist
zeit dass deutschland endlich sein
potenzial los und eine moderne
verwaltung anbietet die die behörden und
bürger in den mittelpunkt stellt
ehrenamt führer verehrte damen und
herren wird aber vor allem in den
bereichen mit dem haushalt bestärkt wo
wir durch politische bildung
medienkompetenz und prävention eine
wirksame bereicherung in unserem
gesellschaftlichen zusammenleben
erfahren werden für mehr toleranz
respekt demokratie und gegen rassismus
unsere gedanken sind heute bei den
angehörigen von weiter luft
dunja kaiser war das aus der
spd-fraktion in der debatte über den
etat des bundesinnenministeriums in
dieser debatte jetzt matthias helferich
afd aber trotzdem fraktionslos
vielen dank frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte damen und herren bereits der
philosoph alexy de tocqueville warnte
dass der demokratie stets die gefahr
innewohne sich in eine tyrannis der
mehrheit zu entwickeln er schreibt die
mehrheit zieht einen drohenden kreis um
das denken innerhalb dieser grenzen ist
man frei aber wehe wenn man sie zu
überschreiten war auch heute droht
unsere demokratie schaden zu nehmen sie
alle bestätigen unsere feier ordnung
wenn sie opposition im parlament
ausgrenzen gar kriminalisieren eines
ihrer instrumente ist der
verfassungsschutz welcher mit rund 488
millionen euro ausgestattet wird zwölf
millionen euro erhalten die schlapphüte
im vergleich zum vorjahr mehr zwölf
millionen euro doch wofür eigentlich vor
dem tunesischen terror fahrer anis ambri
konnte der vsg unser volk nicht schützen
wohl aber scheint der vsg die regierung
eifrig vor der demokratischen opposition
zu schützen die opposition wird aber als
lästiger kontrolleur machtbewusst durch
sie alle durch das establishment
ausgegrenzt den parlamenten
parlamentarischen kontrollgremium
welches die tätigkeit des
verfassungsschutz überwacht darf kein
afd
fantasie dem vertrauensgremium des
haushaltsausschusses was die mittel
zuwendung für den verfassungsschutz
überwacht darf ebenfalls kein
fdp-abgeordnete tagen gehören unter
wundern sie sich ernsthaft noch dass die
bürger unseres landes das vertrauen in
die demokratie verlieren sie schalten
den willen des demos aus und bauen
unsere demokratie schamlos in eine
parteien herrschaft aus ein weiteres
indiz dafür ist während die stiftung des
establishments ich immer hemmungsloser
an steuergeld laden wird die alf dna
stiftung keine mittel erhalten der grund
man wirft ihr fehlende verfassungstreue
vor und wer ist der ankläger ihr
instrumentalisiert verfassungsschutz der
nicht von der opposition kontrolliert
werden darf transparenz und
oppositionelle mitspracherechte sind für
sie lediglich makulatur die realität in
diesem hause ist brutale macht politik
ein hinweis sei mir erlaubt die 800.000
euro für ihre extremismus studie wären
sehr gut angelegt wenn sie als erstes
forschungsprojekt den ober schlapphut
und verfassungsschutz präsidenten thomas
halbe wand wählen würden keiner betreibt
so leidenschaftlich wie er als
installierte behörden extrem ist die
jagd auf die demokratische opposition in
unserem land vielen dank
[Applaus]
helferich für die bezeichnung gehörten
extremist erteile ich ihnen einen
ordnungsruf
da denkt dann auf einen ordnungsrufen
mit auf seinen platz in einer letzten
reihe und obwohl im moment der fraktion
nicht angehört aber doch der partei
haben auch noch einige applaudiert aus
den reihen in der fraktion der fdp wir
sind jetzt tatsächlich bei der
vorletzten rednerinnen angekommen
marlene schönberger bündnis 90 die
grünen
sprechen wir wieder über die realität
wann haben wir das letzte mal jüdische
eltern gefragt wie fühlt es sich
eigentlich an eure kinder an der polizei
vorbei zu jüdischen kita zu bringen und
ihnen die sicherheitsmaßnahmen zu
erklären warum haben wir uns daran
gewöhnt dass jüdinnen und juden hinter
stahl betonen mauern und kugelsicherem
glas beten müssen wann haben wir die
blutspur antisemitischer gewalt
akzeptiert wie sie runden steinke in
seinem buch terror gegen juden
beschreibt wie können wir es zulassen
dass antisemitismus alltag ist
liebe kolleginnen es reicht nicht sich
auf ritualisierten nie wieder auszuruhen
es ist unsere gemeinsame pflicht die
erfahrungen jüdischer menschen in
deutschland zu hören und unser handeln
weiter daran auszurichten so wie wir es
im koalitionsvertrag beschlossen haben
und beginnen jetzt im ersten haushalte
umzusetzen
wir stärken den antisemitismus
beauftragten wir stärken jüdischen
initiativen den rücken für ihren einsatz
für eine demokratische gesellschaft für
vielfalt und gegen verschwörungs
ideologien und die förderung jüdischen
lebens es bedeutet für uns auch das wird
das drängende problem der altersarmut
von jüdinnen und juden endlich angehen
wir legen mit dem härtefall- vor den
grundstein dafür
liebe kolleginnen für die nächsten
haushaltsjahre liegen wichtige aufgaben
vor uns antisemitische gewalt und nicht
nur von rechts von islamisten sowie
teilen der politischen linken
antisemitismus ist bis in die
vermeintliche mitte der gesellschaft
hinein alltag der schutz jüdischer
einrichtungen eine beschämende
notwendigkeit dabei kann es nicht sein
dass jüdische gemeinden selbst für den
schutz vor antisemitischen angriffen
aufkommen müssen die sicherheit
jüdischen lebens ist eine
gemeinschaftsaufgabe
[Applaus]
hier bestehen defizite defizite die
leben kosten können das werden wir in
absprache mit den jüdischen gemeinden
angehen und genauso werden wir die
ursache den antisemitismus bekämpfen mit
prävention intervention und repression
das heißt mit politischer bildung und
monitoring mit polizei und
sicherheitsbehörden die antisemitismus
auf erkennen und mit gerichten die ihn
auch konsequenter bahn haben die
kollegen ich will dass es vor jüdischen
kindergärten schulen keine polizei mehr
stehen muss ich will das würde einen
juden keine neuen anschläge fürchten
müssen ich will dass wir etwas tun gegen
antisemitismus bei demonstrationen auf
unseren schulhöfen am arbeitsplatz und
im internet ich will dass wir jeden
antisemitismus immer und überall
bekämpfen und ich weiß dass das alle
demokratischen fraktionen wollen
diese haushalt leistet einen wichtigen
beitrag dazu vielen dank
malene schöneberger aus der fraktion
bündnis 90 die grünen noch mal auch mit
einem appell aber auch mit einer
forderung an die bundesregierung
jüdische mitbewohnerinnen und
mitbewohnern mehr zu schützen und die
letzte redner in der debatte jetzt aber
sabine poschmann die sportpolitische
sprecherin der spd fraktion
denn ohne breitensport keinen
spitzensport als
top athletin wird man nicht geboren
sondern man wächst hinein und entwickelt
sich
in meiner heimatstadt dortmund erlebe
ich durch die olympiastützpunkte und
natürlich durch die vielen engagierten
vereine die hervorragende arbeit
geleistet wird gerade in der pandemie
sehr kreativ da ist es gut meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren dass wir als
zuständige für den spitzensport auch den
breitensport unter die arme greifen
an rund 120 millionen menschen in
deutschland sind mitglied in einem
sportverein
welche positiven auswirkungen sport auf
die gesundheit den geist das miteinander
hat brauche ich hier nicht zu erläutern
aber deshalb ist es wichtig und richtig
dass wir erstens gerade jetzt ein
riester für den sport hinbekommen und
finanziell ausstatten dabei steht für
mich die qualifizierung und
weiterbildung von übungsleitern im fokus
aber
auch den menschen den zugang zum sport
wieder zu erleichtern
zweitens ist es wichtig dass wir bei der
sanierung von sportstätten eine
ordentliche schippe drauflegen und
dabei
und das ist auch wieder jetzt er
wechselt und dabei nachhaltigkeit eine
wichtige rolle spielt
vor allem sollten die athletinnen und
athleten immer im vordergrund stehen
deshalb freut es mich dass wir hat leben
deutschland zusätzlich finanziell
ausstatten und den grundstein für ein
zentrum safe sport leben
für diese ergebnisse danke ich den
haushältern und haushältern der
koalition
insbesondere martin gerster und roche
mit
um jetzt
voran zu kommen
was sechs jahre teilweise in einem cdu
ministerium nicht passiert ist zum
beispiel bei der spitzensport reform
muss jetzt endlich eine passende
umsetzung erfolgen lassen sie uns mal
damen und herren in bewegung bleiben und
gemeinsam mit den verbänden aber auch
mit den athletinnen und athleten
gestalten das ist das schlüsselwort
herzlichen dank
sabine poschmann nochmal zum thema sport
das ja auch in den bereich der
bundesinnenminister in feld und ganz
nebenbei sabine poschmann leitet
zusammen mit dirk wiese den bvb fanclub
bundestags bewusst im bundestag und
jetzt gibt einiges abzustimmen zum
beispiel zwei änderungsanträge hören wir
rein was vize-präsidentin aydan özoguz
aufruft
stimmen wer stimmt für den
änderungsantrag der fraktion der cdu/csu
auf drucksache 20 48 da geht es unter
anderem um das notfall informations und
notfall informationen und nachrichten
app nina und andere informationstechnik
im bereich zum des katastrophenschutzes
ein änderungsantrag abgelehnt wer stimmt
für den änderungsantrag der fraktion der
afg auf drucksache 20 49 das ist die afg
fraktion dabei wird es mutmaßlich auch
bleiben und es geht um die gesamtsumme
der förderung politischer stiftungen
übrigens und um den antrag der fw
fraktion die desi delius erasmus
stiftung in diese förderung mit
aufzunehmen gesehen auch das ist
abgelehnt worden jetzt die abstimmung
zum einzelplan 06 des bundesministerium
des innern und für heimat das ist cdu
csu fdp und die linke enthaltung keine
dann ist der einzelplan 06 angenommen
wir kommen nun zur abstimmung über den 1
plan 21 bundesbeauftragter für den
datenschutz und die informationsfreiheit
in der ausschuss fassung wer stimmt
dafür
dass linke spd und 90 die grünen fdp cdu
csu wer stimmt dagegen
niemand wer enthält sich die afg
fraktion damit ist der einzelplan 21
angenommen ich rufe auf den einzelplan
bundesministerium für wirtschaft und
klimaschutz mit den
beschlussempfehlungen des
haushaltsausschusses auf drucksachen 16
9 und 16 26 und ich baue darauf dass sie
ganz zügig ihre plätze wechseln
und vielleicht auch etwas geräuschloser
da sind wir mal gespannt ob das jetzt
funktioniert ja zu diesem etat der jetzt
aufgerufen wird der rund elf milliarden
euro umfasst muss man ja tatsächlich gar
nicht viel sagen werden das ist eines
der zentralen thema themen in den
vergangenen monaten dass die in dieses
ressort fallen von bundeswirtschafts-
und klimaschutzminister beck der auch
schon eine ganze weile hier im plenum
angekommen ist und auch bei der vorigen
debatte schon zugehört hat gasspeicher
beispielsweise die 200 milliarden euro
für den klimaschutz
die konzertierte aktion die der
bundeskanzler gestern arg ins gespräch
gebracht hat der ausbau von windenergie
dann ist er innerlich die spritpreise zu
kontrollieren so hat es jedenfalls
die fdp formuliert in diesen tagen und
ja all das beschäftigt uns schon geraume
zeit wird es auch gleich seinen
widerhall finden in dieser debatte in
der der erste redner sein wird andreas
mattfeldt aus der unionsfraktion
das ganze wird 90 minuten dauern von
jetzt an und jetzt wird auch der erste
redner aufgerufen hier einsteigen
ja sehr geehrte frau
präsidentin meine sehr geehrten damen
und herren bevor ich in die feinheiten
des haushaltes einsteige dann möchte ich
mich bei ihnen herr minister habe ich
möchte mich bei ihrem haus
stellvertretend bei ihrer
staatssekretärin anja hajduk und
natürlich beim gesamten haushalts
referaten stephanie will hat an der
spitze für eine außergewöhnlich gute
zusammenarbeit bedanken
mein dank gilt aber auch allen mit
berichterstattern für den fairen und im
menschlichen umgang über alle
fraktionsgrenzen hinweg allerdings
und hier komme ich nie zur debatte über
den haushalt 20 22 hätte ich mir science
der ampel koalition schon gewünscht dass
ihr euch die anträge von uns als union
ein wenig genauer einfach mal angeschaut
hätte anstelle dieser eintrag war er
sagt falscher absender einfach immer nur
weg zum bügeln ich glaube es wäre klug
und das war auch eigentlich sonst immer
üblich bei der einen oder anderen sache
hier gemeinsam zu agieren das haben sie
nicht getan
mit
13,1 2 milliarden
mitteln im einzelplan 09 unter habe mit
noch mehr mitteln im energie und
klimafonds hätte man glaube ich mehr als
genug möglichkeiten gehabt züge und auch
sinnvolle ansätze aus reihen der
opposition zumindest anzudenken gegebene
zeit sogar umzusetzen überhaupt nicht
nachvollziehen konnte ich herr habeck
warum sie unseren antrag zur erneuten
teilnahme des wirtschaftsministeriums
eine jugendmesse ideen expo in hannover
schlichtweg abgelehnt haben mehrfach
habe ich auch sie persönlich hierauf
angesprochen meine empörung während der
ausschusssitzung ich glaube die es ihnen
auch nicht verborgen geblieben auf der
ideenexpo meine damen und herren da
haben junge leute die chance sich über
technische berufe zu informieren und was
das wichtigste ist sie können mit ganz
zahlreichen unternehmen persönlich in
kontakt treten ich glaube nur so
begegnen wir den fachkräftemangel gerade
in diesen so wichtigen mangelberufen es
müssen doch nicht noch mehr menschen
politikwissenschaften studieren da haben
wir hier im saal was gott ja auch schon
mehr als genügend von und wenn ich das
sagen darf ihre vorgänger peter altmaier
regierte zypries die haben es sich nicht
nehmen lassen genau wie 400.000 junge
menschen auf der ideenexpo diesen einem
besuch abzustatten sie waren sogar
richtig stolz auf den stand ihres
ministeriums und unter ihrer führung er
habe hat sich dieser stand jetzt
erledigt aber vielleicht wenn sie in
sich gehen denken sie hierüber ja noch
einmal nach und meine damen und herren
mehr zielorientiertes handeln der ampel
das hätten wir uns auch im bereich der
beruflichen bildung erhofft bei der
ausstattung der fortbildungseinrichtung
und der überbetrieblichen
lehrlingsausbildung
abgelehnten maßgabe beschluss formuliert
dass wir diese titel dauerhaft und ich
betone dauerhaft und nicht nur einmalig
gut ausstatten müssen nur so
signalisieren wir doch eine
wertschöpfung für ausbildungsberufe und
das gerade im handwerk und mehr erhofft
er habe das hätte ich auch beim
zentralen innovationsprogramm
mittelstand und industrie forschung egf
diese für die wettbewerbsfähigkeit
unseres landes so erfolgreich mit
wichtigen programme die hätten wir bei
dem zb um 100 millionen euro an müssen
um einen peinlichen neuen antragsstopp
doch zu vermeiden und ähnliches gilt bei
ihnen hier auch für die industrielle
gemeinschaftsforschung und er habe lasse
mich noch ein paar worte zu dem energie
und klimafonds sagen den cia zu 85%
bewirtschaften hier stehen in den
kommenden jahren milliarden beträge in
dreistelliger milliardenhöhe zur
verfügung und leider habe ich bei den
neuen titeln die sie eingebracht haben
bislang sehr sehr wenig konkretes
gesehen und erwarte ich dass sie bis ins
letzte detail jedes projekt und
spezifizieren aber ein wenig mehr als
nur haushaltstitel mitsummen oder gar
das muss man sich auf der zunge zergehen
lassen zahlreiche leer titel
einzubringen mit verlaub da hätte man
viel viel mehr erwarten dürfen nicht
einmal konkrete fragen was man denn in
etwa vor hat und wie die kosten
aufgeteilt werden konnten beantwortet
werden der minister das geht so nicht
hier sind sie noch antworten schuldig
ich hoffe diese werden in den kommenden
wochen und monaten noch kommen und
unverständlich war styles hat ja warum
sie unser konkreten antrag die mittel
für klimaneutrales fliegen um 350
millionen anzuheben genauso abgelehnt
haben wie die förderung zur produktion
von biokraftstoffen oder eben neue
antriebstechnologien in der luft hat
hier haben sie den titel schon um 700
millionen euro gesenkt auch das ist
nicht nachvollziehbar und ich frage mich
ernsthaft wie dies zu ihren öffentlichen
ankündigungen zur klimaneutralität passt
und die größte herausforderung er habe
ich das ist die rohstoffsicherung für
unsere nation
mehrfach glaube ich haben wir beiden
hierüber gesprochen ich habe ihnen
geraten unsere bundesanstalt für
rohstoffe und geowissenschaften hier von
der leine zu lassen damit wir uns
konzessionen für rohstoffe weltweit und
vor allen dingen langfristig sichern und
ich hatte zwischenzeitlich wirklich den
eindruck dass sie das auch so sehen aber
deshalb habe ich es überhaupt nicht
verstanden warum sie unseren antrag hier
100 millionen euro für dauerhaft energie
und rohstoffsicherung einzustellen
schlichtweg abgelehnt haben nicht mal
und das hätte man erwarten müssen einen
eigenen antrag haben sich hierzu
eingebracht und deshalb herr minister
ich stelle zwar fest dass sie das
mediale geschäft grandios beherrschen
sie aber in der umsetzung noch mehr als
gehörig luft nach oben haben und deshalb
dieser dieser haushalt meine damen und
herren er ist alles andere als ein
zukunftssignal im gegenteil mit den
durch die koalition und ihr haus
eingebrachten anträge haben sie ihn
leider in keiner weise verbessert man
kann ihn daher nur ablehnen herzlichen
dank
als nächster redner erhält felix paschek
für bündnis 90 grünen dieses wort
vielen dank frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
hersfeld reden nicht andersrum machen
ist wir reden nur geil das ist glaube
ich der das ist glaube ich das ist
glaube ich der geist mit dem diese
koalition mit dem robert habeck jetzt
wirtschafts und klimaschutzpolitik
machen und übrigens auch zusammen machen
jeder setzt die prioritäten für sich
selbst aber dass sie jetzt ausgerechnet
auf die punkte einige jahre sind hermann
in ihrer rede wo diese koalition liefert
ja beispielsweise dabei dass es die
erste koalition ist die dafür sorgt dass
wir den drittel an scheidet bei der
unterstützung des bundes für die
überbetriebliche lehrlingsausbildung
macht sie haben sie gemacht sind es
immer angekündigt nie getan wir machen
70 millionen sind jetzt drin
das thema angesprochen und auch hier
muss man sich überlegen ob man wirklich
in der richtigen position ist dass
anzukreiden weil wir ja die situation
vorgefunden haben dass die
vorgängerregierung mit peter altmaier
als bundesminister die mittel so gekürzt
haben dass es zudem antragsstopp kam
denn diese koalition in der
bereinigungssitzung mit 80 millionen
euro
verpflichtungsermächtigung für das
kommende jahr aufgelöst hat diese
koalition hat den staubblättern sie
verursacht haben so ist doch die lage
und
ich muss ihnen gestehen für mich ist das
gerade in gewisser performative
widerspruch eine performative
herausforderung weil ich seit dem 15 mit
der gut gelaunten christdemokratinnen
und des christdemokraten über die
zukunft nordrhein westfalen sprechen und
wie er da so schöne sätze im sondierungs
papier vereinbaren konnte ich glaube
dass es ein gemeinsames verständnis gibt
die sagen wir werden die notwendigen
zukunftsinvestitionen tätigen und dafür
instrumente entwickeln und von ihnen
hier im bundestag erleben wir ja nur
destruktion die verhinderung von
investitionen beispielsweise durch die
klage gegen 60 milliarden euro für den
energie und klimafonds und der gipfel
des ganzen ist ja herr kollege mattfeldt
dass ihre ganzen ideen was alles
ausgestattet werden sollte im einzelplan
und 9 und dem energie- und klimafonds
der jetzt der klima und
transformationsphase ist sind ja
folgende streichens vorschläge erstens
zu streichen weil der internationalen
klimaschutzinitiative dazu komme ich
gleich noch und zweitens ist ihre
gegenfinanzierung das ist gestern
ausgeführt worden ihre gegenfinanzierung
für all die vorschläge ist die 60
milliarden euro von denen sie sagen die
dürfte es gar nicht geben jetzt wieder
in den haushalt reinzuziehen was hat das
mit solider mit ehrlicher hat wird
redlicher haushaltspolitik zu tun für
die sie sich doch wie man vielleicht dem
sie sich an den kolleginnen und kollegen
nordrhein westfalen ein beispiel
frau präsident liebe kolleginnen
kollegen was machen wir mit diesem
haushalt den wir jetzt verändert haben
wir machen war was andere nur
angekündigt haben angela merkel die
bundeskanzlerin hat in der vergangenheit
angekündigt worden sechs milliarden euro
für den internationalen klima und
diversität schutz
schaffen ja wir sind diesem ziel immer
noch nicht ganz nahe gekommen aber diese
regierung meine damen und herren ist die
erste die überhaupt den weg dahin
beschreiten will die aus den
ankündigungen vor denen man dann für die
man dann in den internationalen
konferenzen applaus bekommt auch taten
wachsen dass die priorisiert die ernst
nimmt dass sie klima und die
biodiversitäts krise die beiden großen
ökologischen krisen unserer zeit auch
den wohlstand der zukunft bedrohen und
deswegen ist der organisations erlasse
dafür gesorgt hat dass klimaschutz und
wirtschaft endlich kein widerspruch mehr
sind dass das innenministerium
verhindert dass das andere gerne machen
würde dass es zusammen denkt so ein
quantensprung in der
bundesrepublikanischen politik und ich
kann mir nur wünschen dass wir den weg
weitergehen den wir jetzt beschritten
haben
denn liebe kolleginnen und kollegen das
multiple das multiple krisen szenario
vor dem wir stehen erfordert endlich
aufzuhören nur dinge anzukündigen und
erfordert ins handeln zu kommen die
klimakrise die biodiversitäts krise der
völkerrechtswidrige angriffskrieg gegen
die ukraine die vielfältigen
schwerwiegenden auswählt auswirkungen
auf die deutsche wirtschaft auf den
mittelstand die brauchen eben auch die
entsprechende unterstützung und ich
finde man muss auch einfach mal
anerkennen dass es diese regierung ist
und das ist ein grüner bundesminister
für wirtschaft und klimaschutz ist der
die ziele nicht aus dem blick verliert
aber eben im umgang mit diesen krisen im
umgang mit dem dilemma situationen die
wir haben pragmatische wege geht das
bedeutet die versorgungssicherheit jetzt
zu gewährleisten und gleichzeitig den
ambitionierten umstiegs und
transformationsphase in die wege zu
leiten das tun wir mit dem einzelplan
und 9 das tun wir mit dem einzelplan 60
und dem energie- und klimafonds und das
tun wir mit ganz konkreten
regierungshandeln wie jetzt im oster
paket und in einigen wochen dann im
sommer paket ich freue mich auf die
weitere zusammenarbeit in der koalition
in der wir uns auf gute dinge
verständigen konnten und sicherlich noch
viele gute dinge entwickeln werden
vielen dank
nächster redner ist für die afg fraktion
wolfgang riehle
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin
kolleginnen und kollegen frühere
debatten über den haushalt des
bundeswirtschaftsministeriums handelten
vom richtigen weg zu mehr
wirtschaftswachstum und wohlstand sei
das haus unter grüner führung der steht
geht es hauptsächlich um eine
ideologische transformation von
wirtschaft und gesellschaft die
deutschland und europa im weltmaßstab
weit zurückwerfen wird
es ist kein zufall dass jetzt die
inflation steigt und die aussichten
düster sind der krieg in der ukraine hat
die vorgezeichnete entwicklung bloß noch
beschleunigt immer mehr bürger aber auch
wirtschaftslenker senken ihre
zukunftserwartungen weil die grüne
politik keine besseren hoffnungen
erlaubt
wenn co2
planziele das maß aller dinge sind und
regelmäßig verschärft werden dann sind
wir mit siebenmeilenstiefeln auf dem weg
in die unproduktive planwirtschaft
nicht nur der haushalt des ministeriums
finanziert das ganze sondern auch der
sogenannte energie und klimafonds rund
10 milliarden euro kommen für staatliche
wirtschaftslenkung zusammen eine 7
milliarden für die einseitige förderung
der e mobilität über eine milliarde für
dekarbonisierung der industrie und auch
hier rund 30 millionen für dinge wie
grünen strahl und das klimaneutrale
schippen
dass das unsere zukunft sein sollen
glaubt das volk nicht von selbst dafür
ist viel propaganda nötig und auch die
politischen hilfstruppen der grünen
werden aus dem haushalt bedient da wird
eine klimaschutzkampagne gefördert
und eine klima allianz genauso selbst
den vom ministerium bezahlten
bürgerdialog stromnetz betreibt ein grün
radikale abmahn verein die sogenannte
deutsche umwelthilfe
diese
nichtregierungsorganisation oder besser
regierungs hilfsorganisationen haben
große macht nehmen wir zb agora
energiewende dieser verein schlägt vor
künftig unser gasnetz zurückzubauen also
aus dem boden zu reißen sein früherer
direktor patrick reichel ist heute
staatssekretär im ministerium habeck und
wiederholt diese forderung im namen der
regierung
was heißt das für unser land ich nenne
das energiewende brutal wenn man später
nämlich merkt dass diese energiewende in
richtung steinzeit führt ist die brücke
auf dem rückweg schon abgerissen
genau dieselbe strategie verfolgt die
regierung mit der zerstörung der co2
freien kernenergie die afg verfolgt
einen völlig anderen weg wir fordern
eine energie sicherheits wende in
zukunft muss die energieversorgung
wieder sicher seien dazu gehören
kernenergie gas öl und kohle und genauso
wind und sonne
es darf keine sanktionen geben die
deutschland am meisten schaden wenn
ungarns ministerpräsident orban für
seine bürger durchsetzt dass die eu
alleine weiter fließen lässt dann muss
deutschland das nutzen statt ablehnen
diese haltung herr minister habeck ist
arroganz und verkauft deutsche
interessen
damit deutschland eine gute zukunft hat
brauchen wir keine energie oder
verkehrswende sondern eine politikwende
der ideologen geldspeicher namens
energie und klimafonds muss aufgelöst
werden die bürger müssen auch künftig
sich das autofahren und das heizen
leisten können dann würde man wieder von
politik für den wohlstand reden und das
fordern wir von dfds
[Applaus]
folgt für die spd-fraktion der kollege
frank junge
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen meine sehr geehrten damen und
herren kabila angesichts ihrer immer
wieder und permanent vorgetragenen
kruden ansichten bin ich ganz froh
darüber dass die leute in
wahlergebnissen ausdrücken was sie auch
politisch von ihnen halten und das
dokumentieren ja auch gerade die
jüngsten wahlen die an dieser stelle
stattgefunden haben
in diesen zeiten des verbrecherischen
angriffskrieg putin auf die ukraine in
den zeiten in dem wir die korona krise
noch lange nicht überwunden haben und in
den zeiten in denen wir vor
existenziellen und
generationenübergreifenden
zukunftsaufgaben stehen ist es aus
meiner sicht wichtig dass der
stabilitäts- schafft und
handlungsfähigkeit bewahrt und liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen genau das
dokumentiert der einzelplan des
wirtschaftsministeriums genau das ist es
was wir vorlegen damit stellen wir das
kennen wir nicht nur die notwendigen
mittel bereit um die äußere innere
sicherheit und auch die soziale
sicherzustellen wir eröffnen damit auch
ein jahrzehnt der investitionen den
größenordnungen um die zukunftsfähigkeit
unseres landes zu gewährleisten darauf
kommt es an damit wir im globalen
maßstab die wettbewerbsfähigkeit unserer
wirtschaft sichern zusammen mit den
verstärkungen mitteln aus dem ktf sind
jetzt insgesamt 11 milliarden euro auf
dem tisch und wir haben sie an dieser
stelle natürlich eingesetzt und den
klimaschutz voranzutreiben die
transformation von industrie wirtschaft
und mobilität voran zu führen die
weiterentwicklung der
wasserstoffwirtschaft voranzubringen
innovationsförderung vorzunehmen und
auch strukturschwäche im land weiter zu
begleiten
all das war uns in der ampelkoalition
wichtig all das findet sich auch im
rahmen dieses haushalts wieder und zudem
sichern wir eine gasversorgung die viel
breiter aufgestellt ist als bisher wir
bauen eine lng infrastruktur aus wir
bauen die erneuerbaren energien aus und
schaffen damit endlich einen übergang in
eine energieversorgung die uns
unabhängig von preisentwicklungen derart
macht wie wir sie jetzt haben und auch
das ist etwas was der wirtschaft in
unglaublichem maße zugute kommt
natürlich war es uns als andere
haushälter wichtig die großen linien aus
dem koalitionsvertrag zu bedienen das
ist hier an der stelle auch von felix ja
schon gestrichen worden also wenn wir
hier über die energetische
gebäudesanierung sprechen mit elf
milliarden euro sind das wahnsinnig
wichtige komplexe die dekarbonisierung
der industriestadt rinne die tank und
ladeinfrastruktur
die digitalisierung der wirtschaft alter
sind milliardenbeträge die genau dort
angesetzt werden können wo sie nicht nur
für die umstellung unserer wirtschaft im
rahmen des transformationsprozesses gilt
sie sind auch wichtig dafür um impulse
zu setzen wirtschaftliche anreize zu
vollziehen und am ende damit auch
wirtschaftswachstum zu generieren
wir haben dazu auch im einzelplan 09 die
automobilindustrie weiter gestärkt die
luft und raumfahrt und auch den
schiffbau auf hohem niveau verstetigt
und wir haben an der stelle auch dafür
gesorgt dass wir eigene akzente setzen
und lieber kollege matt fällt das muss
ich jetzt dann doch auch noch mal sagen
du hast beklagt dass wir eure anträge
nicht zur kenntnis genommen oder sogar
umgesetzt haben das liegt einfach daran
dass wir uns in der einzelplan beratung
für 200 millionen euro ungedeckte
schecks vorgelegt habt ohne jeglichen
ansatz einer deckung und in der
bereinigungssitzung habt ihr dort
grössenordnungen im rahmen der
aufgezeigt felix hat es gesagt die
bedeutet hätten die deckung aus dem kfd
mirja beklagt hervor zu nehmen und das
ist an der schule so absurd und
unlogisch und in meiner ansicht auch
verantwortung
wir haben mit den akzenten die wir
gesetzt haben ganz besonders wert darauf
gelegt die kleinen mittelständischen
unternehmen zu unterstützen tim ist ein
beispiel dafür
die die 20 millionen erhöhung ist dort
ein ganz wichtiger baustein und wir
haben an der stelle auch dafür gesorgt
dass wir mit der
verpflichtungsermächtigung von 80
millionen euro für das nächste jahr
nicht wieder in ein loch fallen so wie
es die haushaltsplanung von peter
altmaier jetzt gebracht hatte die
industrieforschung ist ein weiterer
bestandteil dafür die kleinen
unternehmen zu stärken und wenn ich noch
zwei punkte nennen darf dann will ich
vor allen dingen die grw nennen die
gemeinschaftsaufgabe regionale
wirtschaftsstruktur ist etwas was
insbesondere strukturschwachen regionen
hilft und unsere auf besserung um
weitere 25 millionen euro hilft genau
dort wo es dringend benötigt wird 80
prozent dieser mittel fließen dazu noch
in den osten wo im rahmen der
angleichung der lebensverhältnisse noch
viel geleistet werden muss und das ist
ein punkt der uns ganz wichtig war und
der zu herauszustellen ist und letzter
punkt ich hier noch nennen will das ist
der und dann begreife ich auch gar nicht
andreas wie du das kritisieren kannst
wir haben den aufwuchs der
überbetrieblichen lehrlingsausbildung
vorgenommen damit ist das handwerk
glücklich genauso glücklich darüber dass
wir fünf millionen mehr für die
investition in die in die
bildungsinfrastruktur für das handwerk
gegeben haben das sind alles maßnahmen
die dokumentieren ganz klar und vor
allen dingen auch mit deckungs vermerken
untersetzt was wir vorhaben wo unsere
schwerpunkte liegen und wie wichtig uns
diese entwicklung sind liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen ich komme zum schluss der
einzelplan 09 stellt nicht nur wie ich
finde ein verantwortungsvolles
herangehen an die globalen krisen da den
dem wir uns stellen müssen wir bringen
damit mit diesem etat auch die energie
wärme und mobilitäts wende weiter voran
wir nehmen damit unsere unternehmen mit
besetzten anreiz und impulse wir
schaffen es so sie zu stärken und wir
sichern an dieser stelle auf diese art
und weise natürlich verlässlichkeit und
planungssicherheit und wir schaffen
somit auch ein stück weit beschäftigung
und weiteren wohlstand deshalb bitte ich
sie um zustimmung zu diesem haushalt
sagt franke junge aus der spd-fraktion
der zuvor den blick auf kleine
unternehmen und auch in die regionen
gerichtet hatte in dieser debatte in der
es um den etat für das ministerium für
wirtschaft und klimaschutz geht und da
spricht jetzt victor perli aus der links
fraktion sprecher für umverteilung
herzlichen dank frau präsidentin sind
meine damen und herren die menschen in
unserem land müssen die steigenden
preise bei energie und lebensmitteln
die hohe inflation teuer bezahlen auch
mittelschicht familien müssen sich
einschränken wir angst vor der
heizkostenabrechnung ist groß wir
steuern auf eine armutsfalle zu wie sie
dieses land noch nicht gesehen hat wer
es schon vor dem krieg schwer hatte über
die runden zu kommen weiß heute nicht
wovon der am ende des monats leben soll
wir sehen das daran dass die schlangen
vor den tafeln immer länger werden und
die ampel koalition beschließt hier
einen haushalt für die
lebenswirklichkeit
dieser millionen menschen ignoriert und
keine gerechtigkeit schafft das ist
wirklich beschämend meine damen und
herren
das deutsche institut für
wirtschaftsforschung hat schwarz auf
weiß bestätigt was die linke von anfang
an gesagt hat die ampel koalition lässt
vor allem rentner menschen mit geringen
einkommen und die ärmsten im stich die
forscher haben nachgewiesen dass der
groß der größte teil ihrer
entlastungspaket
ausgerechnet bei den menschen landet die
die höchsten einkommen haben die reichen
die haben wenigsten hilfe brauchen
bekommen die meiste unterstützung und
diejenigen die am wenigsten haben und am
meisten unterstützung brauchen wir
kommen am wenigsten unterstützung das
ist das gegenteil von sozialer
gerechtigkeit
spd grüne und fdp müssen hier
beantworten wie zu dieser
ungerechtigkeit kommen konnte weil es
ihre absicht
und es ein versehen
so oder so zeigt es dass in dieser
koalition das soziale gewissen nicht
vorhanden ist meine damen und herren
auf den wahlplakaten stand respekt und
gerechtigkeit im haushalt findet sich
nichts davon es ist respektlos dass
rentner und studierende keine 300 euro
energie pauschale bekommen
haben
und in tafeln wenn die schlangen länger
da stehen renten haben die kinder setzen
weil die rente nicht ausreicht
finden sie es nicht geschämt dass die
minister
300 euro pauschale bekommen und die
rentner leer ausgehen ist ihnen das
nicht peinlich meine damen und herren
sorgen sie dafür dass auch die
studierenden es auch die rentner diese
pauschale endlich bekommen
aktuell sehen wir an den tankstellen
dass die mineralölkonzerne sich
bereichern die haben kurz vor der
steuersenkung erst mal kräftig die
preise angehoben und die ampelkoalition
schaut tatenlos zu wie sich da
auf kosten der begründung bürgern die
taschen voll gemacht werden es gibt ein
bundeskartellamt dafür ist ja habig
zuständig das gibt verhaltenstipps wie
man sich verhalten soll anstatt
einzugreifen dafür zu sorgen dass diese
steuer will nur eins zu eins an kommt
bei den menschen
die er vorher eine wirksame
preisaufsicht und eine
überdimensionierte krisen profiteure
damit diejenigen die hier abzocken auch
dank damit belegt werden damit sich
abdrücke nicht lohnt das geld muss mit
dem burgenland kommen und ich finde auch
letzter satz sollten es doch hier einig
sein kein mensch solche angst oder
heizkostenabrechnung haben vielen dank
im victor perli aus der linksfraktion
mit fragen an den
bundeswirtschaftsminister
in diesem fall zu einer pauschale für
sendener antworten darauf möglicherweise
nach den beiden nächsten redner dann
jedenfalls steht der
bundeswirtschaftsminister robert habeck
auf der rednerliste jetzt aber erstmal
karsten klein ob man für die fdp im
haushaltsausschuss
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen anfang der
woche hat die eu ein weiteres
sanktionspaket gegen russland auf den
weg gebracht ich denke das begrüßen wir
alle ausdrücklich aber klar muss auch
sein dass sanktionen dass unser
sanktionsregime dazu führen vor allem
die russische seite die russische
wirtschaft mehr zu schädigen als die
europäische oder die deutschen und das
unsere sanktionen wirken sieht man auch
daran dass hochwertige güter aus europa
und deutschland der russischen
wirtschaft nicht mehr zur verfügung
steht hochwertige güter wie durch andere
staaten die sich an den sanktionen nicht
beteiligen nur schwer zu substituieren
sind das zeigt aber auch noch mal liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen was wir an
stärke in diesem konflikt mit einbringen
die waagschale mit einbringen können
nämlich unsere wirtschaftliche stärke
die möglichkeit dass die menschen in
diesem land ihr know how in güter in
hochwertige dienstleistungen
transferieren können auch für die
freunde in der ukraine und deshalb
deshalb hat die ampel koalition die zwei
kollegen sind ja schon darauf
eingegangen auch noch mal massiv an den
mitteln zugelegt um innovationskraft um
die zukunftsfähigkeit um das know how
dieser menschen zu stärken hier in
diesem land über die berufliche bildung
über das zentrale mittelstandsprogramm
innovation und andere töpfe genau um das
zu erreichen dass wir wettbewerbsfähig
bleiben international und dass wir diese
stärke auch noch in diesem konflikt
einbringen können
die kolleginnen kollegen das gegenteil
von dem die wirtschaftskraft zu
verstärken wäre es gewesen der forderung
nach einem sofortigen gas in waben
nachzukommen
die preise sind für die bürgerinnen
bürger den letzten wochen extrem
gestiegen an der tankstelle bis zu 40
prozent in der spitze beim gas sogar
fast verdoppelt aber das ist nur ein
müder vorgeschmack von dem was passieren
würde wenn wir ein sofortiges gas in bar
wovon verhängen würden und ja es war
eine fehlentscheidung sich so massiv von
russischer energie abhängig zu machen
aber deshalb muss es für uns gelten
gegenstrategien zu entwickeln und das
hat diese bundesregierung getan das hat
diese bundesregierung beteiligen jetzt
um einen kurzfristig die bürger den
bürgern bei der groß gestiegenen
energiepreisen eine abdämpfen
ermöglichen über das entlastungspaket 37
milliarden euro in der summe über die
abschaffung der gmg umlage zum beispiel
oder über den tank rabatt und herr
minister ich bin überzeugt davon dass
sie mit dem kartellamt gemeinsam dafür
sorge tragen werden dass diese preis ab
sendung auch bei den bürgerinnen und
bürgern ankommen wie wir
haben es aber auch getan indem ihr einen
zuschuss bei ihnen einzelplan
eingestellt haben die vier milliarden
euro für die energieintensive wirtschaft
um das zeigt kurzfristig haben wir schon
reagiert aber natürlich bedarf es auch
einer mittelfristigen und langfristigen
strategie um die abhängigkeit von
fossiler russische energie zu reduzieren
und liebe kolleginnen und kollegen der
union da ist natürlich der vorschlag 750
milliarden euro bei der dekarbonisierung
der industrie zu streichen genau das
gegenteil von dem eine strategie zu
entwickeln um die abhängigkeit zu
reduzieren
wir als koalition haben aber in den
haushalt aufgenommen um die abhängigkeit
zu erreichen zum einen investitionen in
infrastruktur bei ihren ski ich begrüße
ausdrücklich dass es hier auch eine
kehrtwende gegeben hat fast vier
milliarden euro für die schwimmenden
plattform und löst um das flüssiggas
auch in unsere systeme zu bringen das
dient natürlich der reduzierung der
abhängigkeit und das dient der
versorgungssicherheit wir dürfen aber in
diesem zusammenhang nicht die
versorgungs preise außer acht lassen und
deshalb müssen wir den menschen auch
sagen in den letzten zehn jahren war
fred war allen tigers immer 30 prozent
teurer als das gas aus den pipelines und
deshalb liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
herr minister muss es uns gelingen den
spirit die idee unseres
koalitionsvertrags auch noch stärker zu
leben wir wollen über innovationen über
fortschritt zu weniger verbrauch kommen
und dazu dass wir uns neue
energiequellen erschließen das sind die
aufgaben für die nächsten monate und
jahre
gut natürlich müssen wir auch dafür
sorgen dass die mittel im haushalt ihre
wirksamkeit verbessern wir haben eine
ganze reihe von rechnungshof berichten
und er hat ihnen ihr vorgänger peter
altmaier und die union ja herr minister
leider eine riesenbaustelle überlassen
diese rechnungshofberichte lägen noch
mal fest dass wir eine sehr schlechte
koordination haben wenn es um die mittel
in der energiewende geht dass wir keine
schlechte wirksamkeit haben bei der
verausgabung dieser mittel wir haben
hohe ausgabereste im bereich des
wirtschaftsministeriums und des energie
und klimafonds und deshalb gilt es das
hat die koalition auch beschlossen dass
wir diese wirksamkeit der mittel erhöhen
denn wir wollen alle gemeinsam erreichen
dass wir nicht mittel in den haushalt
einstellen sondern dass wir co2
einsparen und dass wir uns alternative
energiequellen eröffnen und das muss das
ziel der nächsten monat das sagen vielen
dank wir rauchen
karsten klein war das für die
fdp-fraktion obmann im ausschuss für
wirtschaft und klimaschutz
jetzt jens spahn stellvertretender
vorsitzender der cdu/csu-fraktion
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen die inflation ist auf
rekordniveau der wirtschaftliche
ausblick trübt sich ein eine stagnation
droht die energieversorgung ist
gefährdet in zeiten wie diesen wäre es
gut wenn der wirtschafts und
energieminister einen plan mit klaren
prioritäten vorlegen würde aber in allzu
vielen bereichen und ich will drei
nennen fehlt ein solcher plan erstens zu
innovations- und strukturpolitik gerade
in zeiten der inflation braucht es eine
wachstumsfördernde politik denn wachstum
weitet das angebot aus und dämpft damit
die inflation ein der bundesminister der
finanzen hat ein papier für eine
wachstumsfördernde angebotspolitik
vorgelegt bürokratie abbauen
zumindest die fdp freut sich in der
koalition reber bürokratieabbau und
arbeitsrecht flexibilisieren anreize für
investitionen setzen zum beispiel so ein
papier der wirtschaftsminister hätten
wir uns auch von ihnen gewünscht denn
nur wenn sie die beiden sich einig sind
finanz und wirtschaftsminister dann
kommt eine wachstumspolitik auch
zustande schiller und strauss das war
ein plüsch und plumpen habeck und
lindner das ist eher wie tom und jerry
wie katz und maus aber wird das ist
unterhaltsam was wir brauchen es aber
nicht ein katz und maus spiel was wir
brauchen ist ein kohärentes konzept von
finanz- und wirtschaftspolitik in diesen
zeiten
gestern sagten sie rezession vermeiden
kaufkraft erhalten gerechtigkeit walten
lassen das sei das ziel alles nette
überschriften alles soweit richtig aber
was will diese regierung konkret
in zeiten von rekord inflation
und unsicherheit in der wirtschaft tun
die bürgerinnen und bürger und ja auch
dieses parlament haben einen anspruch
darauf endlich mal einen kohärenten
planen zu bekommen gleich haben sie die
gelegenheit dazu er minister
ein zweites beispiel ist die
energiepolitik
wir seien sehr gut vorbereitet falls wir
kein russisches gas im winter bekäme
sagen wirtschaftsminister und kanzler
den eindruck habe ich ehrlich gesagt
noch nicht der deutsche bundestag hat
vor zwei monaten vor zwei monaten mit
stimmen von spd union grünen und fdp die
bundesregierung aufgefordert einen
ausstiegsfahrplan vorzulegen mal genau
darzulegen jenseits von interviews und
einzelnen äußerungen wie viel
terawattstunden etwa an energie aus gas
wie er bis wann ersetzen wollen bei den
russischen lieferungen durch was bis
jetzt haben wir dazu keinen konkreten
plan es hieß vor zwei monaten
kurzfristig cam lieferungen aus katar
gas jetzt heißt es ist kein 2024 werden
nichts genaues weiß man nicht
gasspeicher sie haben ein gesetzentwurf
vorgelegt um kohle sie haben einen
gesetzentwurf vorgelegt zum gas stoff
und sagen
kohlekraftwerke sollen möglicherweise am
netz bleiben auch braunkohlekraftwerke
bemerkenswerterweise um dann im fall der
fälle einzuspringen warum nicht jetzt
schon eigentlich müssten wir doch schon
das sagen wir seit zwei monaten seit
wochen stärker kohlekraftwerke nutzen in
dieser zeit um gas zu sparen bei den gas
gab und gespeichert zu füllen werden sie
uns vor zwei monaten gefolgt hätten wir
jetzt schon 23 prozent voller regale
speicher liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
und den übrigen verstehe ich auch nicht
bis heute nicht auch in der aktuellen
debatte warum ein grüner klimaminister
lieber kohle auch pro
braunkohlekraftwerke im fall der fälle
am netz lässt als co2 neutrale
kernkraftwerke die noch laufen weiter
laufen zu lassen das will mir nicht in
den sinn herr ballack hat zu recht
darauf hingewiesen und wir unterstützen
sie dabei haben mehrfach zugestimmt sie
sind an vielen stellen pragmatisch und
tun dinge die sie sonst nicht getan
hätten und das ist anzuerkennen und das
unterstützen wir ausdrücklich aber es
wäre eben auch gut wenn sie in dieser
frage pragmatismus und nicht ideologie
walten ließen die aktuelle situation
erfordert ist die interessierte
kolleginnen und kollegen
ein drittes beispiel die handelspolitik
sie haben gesagt energiepolitik ist
sicherheitspolitik unter stimmt auch
handelspolitik ist sicherheitspolitik
das hat drei dimensionen die globale
dimension freihandel wirkt gegen armut
verbindet uns mit der welt und mit den
partnern die unsere werte teilen
die dimensionen der
versorgungssicherheit freihandel mit
verschiedenen verlässlichen partnern
steigert die resilienz unserer
lieferkette und drittens auch die
dimensionen unsere unternehmen und
beschäftigten freihandel sicherte in
deutschland etwa viereinhalb millionen
arbeitsplätze und damit auch das
einkommen von millionen familien und
auch da könnten sie ein wichtiges
zeichen setzen wir setzen es jede woche
hier auf zur abstimmung während sie gas
in katar gibt ein richtiger weise kaufen
verweigern sie bis heute dem freihandel
mit kanada die zustimmung hier im
deutschen bundestag die fdp selbst die
minister der fdp fordern mittlerweile
öffentlich die zustimmung wir fordern
sie auf in zeiten wie diesen lassen sie
uns endlich das handelsabkommen mit
kanada ratifizieren und eine zustimmung
hier im deutschen bundestag erreichen
man muss man muss nur herrn
ministerpräsidenten kretschmann in
dieser frage folgen mit dem stimmen wir
davon überhaupt kein problem ich
verstehe gar nicht warum an bestimmten
stellen so viel pragmatismus möglich ist
richtigerweise und an anderen stellen da
weder die ideologie überwiegt wir müssen
alle in zeiten wie diesen ein job bereit
an vielen stellen und reichen die hand
dazu mit ihnen zusammenzuarbeiten
aber sie müssen sich auch schon ertragen
wir sind staatstragend in zeiten wie
diesen aber wir sind nicht regierungs
tragen sie müssen schon damit rechnen in
diesen zeiten das ist kritik gibt für
das was sie tun oder eben nicht tun
und frau präsidentin abschließend
steuereinnahmen halten das land am
laufen haben es haben sich kürzlich
gesagt der wirtschaftsminister so
ähnlich wie der strom kommt aus der
steckdose oder die milch kommt aus dem
supermarkt denn strom muss produziert
werden bauern müssen die kühe melken und
das geld des staates ist das kommt nicht
vom finanzamt steuereinnahmen müssen
erst einmal erwirtschaften das sind die
bürgerinnen und bürger in diesem land
die das land am laufen halten und das
ist wichtig immer wieder auch zu zeigen
und deutlich zu machen denn das drückt
eine geisteshaltung aus die wir in der
steuerpolitik reden wir über die frage
reden woher das geld kommt und wie wir
mit dem geld umgehen drückt eine
geisteshaltung aus in zeiten wie diesen
halten wir es für wichtig genau das
anzuerkennen und zurückzukehren zur
haushaltskonsolidierung die richtigen
schwerpunkte zu setzen und eine politik
für wachstum zu haben in zeiten der
hohen inflation dazu reichen wir ihnen
gerne die hand
allerlei vorwürfe des früheren
gesundheitsministers und jetzigen
stellvertretenden vorsitzenden der
unionsfraktion jens spahn an den
bundeswirtschaftsminister er solle etwa
pragmatismus statt ideologie walten
lassen die gegenrede vom minister selbst
vielen dank präsidentin sehr geehrte
damen und herren liebe kollegen sparen
geisteshaltung ideologie geologie
vorwurf würde ich sagen muss sich
derjenigen gefallen lassen der den
billigen applaus zuliebe hier phrasen
verkündet ohne die konkrete wirklichkeit
die handlung und die entwicklung in der
wirklichkeit zur kenntnis zu nehmen
um auf die wirklichkeit zu kommen
dieser haushalt und die debatte die wir
führen ist ein besonderer haushalt vor
einer besonderen wirklichkeit viele
aspekte und ich kann in den fünf minuten
die ich habe nicht auf alle eingehen
sind genannt worden die das land
besonders bedrückend aber es hat
natürlich ein grund warum diese
bedrückung da ist und dieser grund ist
der angriffskrieg der durch nichts zu
rechtfertigende angriffskrieg von putin
auf die ukraine der tod der menschen der
dort verursacht wird und die hohen
kosten die druck auf die bevölkerung an
auf die wirtschaft die wir hier zu
tragen haben sehr geehrte damen und
herren aber wir tragen sie erfolgreich
der bundeskanzler hat gestern
aufgelistet welche waffen und welche
waffengattungen die bundesrepublik
deutschland der ukraine zur verfügung
stellt ich möchte kurz darauf eingehen
dass wir uns ebenfalls in einem anderen
konflikt befinden nämlich einem
wirtschafts konflikt wir schauen und
diskutieren wenn wir auf die
sanktionsliste schauen immer über die öl
und die gasverkäufe die russland noch
immer tätigt und ja die einnahmen die
putin
erzielt hat in den letzten monaten durch
die hohen preise sie sind die tun weh
und man kann sich dafür eigentlich nur
schämen dass wir es immer noch nicht
geschafft haben diese abhängigkeit
deutlich zu reduzieren aber
nur auf die einnahmen auf die öl- und
gaseinnahmen von putin zu schauen
verkennt was gerade die wirklich zeit
ist eine wirklichkeit die wir mit mit
den alliierten zusammen herstellen er
kann sich nämlich von dem geld das er
verdient immer weniger ja faktisch
nichts mehr kaufen die russische
wirtschaft bricht ein die exporte nach
russland die importe nach russland für
die russische seite sie gehen dramatisch
zurück
insgesamt sind die exporte der
alliierten derjenigen die sich den
sanktionen angeschlossen haben in den
letzten monaten um 53 prozent
zurückgegangen wichtiger vielleicht noch
dass auch die exporte aus den ländern
die neutral oder sogar prorussisch
aufgestellt sind um 45 prozent
zurückgegangen sind
deutschland mit einem anteil eines
exportrückgangs nach russland um minus
60 prozent allein im märz wir erwarten
eine deutlich höhere zahl im april hat
einen wesentlichen anteil daran dass es
so ist und diese exportrückgang er ist
ja das haben wir bei corona gemerkt wer
ist ja nicht in der allgemeinheit nur zu
erfassen denn was dann fehlt sind teile
in spezifischen die verkehrten die
russische wirtschaft bis ins mark
treffen wird es fehlen
sicherheitsupdates für die flugzeuge mit
der konsequenz dass bald die flugzeuge
am boden bleiben es fehlen technische
güter
value kurz in der technischen kette die
die produktionsprozesse zerstören werden
sehr geehrte damen und herren
putin kriegt noch geld aber er kann es
kaum noch aufgeben und die zeit sie
arbeitet nicht für russland sie arbeitet
gegen russland sie arbeitet gegen die
russische wirtschaft die russische
wirtschaft ist eingebrochen das bild ist
um 9 prozent zurückgegangen die
kreditwürdigkeit russland ist
ramschstatus die investitionstätigkeit
ist um 34 prozent zurückgegangen niemand
will mehr in russland investieren da
kann das nicht mehr lange durchhalten er
kann vielleicht seine armee noch
versorgen mit den möglichkeiten die am
eigenen land hat öl und weizen aber die
russische wirtschaft ist hart getroffen
durch die sanktionen und ein wesen ein
teil davon trägt die deutsche wirtschaft
das sieht das tut das kann man nur mit
dank sagen beantworten
einen wesentlichen teil davon
die deutsche bevölkerung
wir haben über die hohen belastungen
gesprochen und auch da muss man sagen
danke dafür denn wir tun ist ja nicht
aus spaß wir tun ist um die russische
und die putins wirtschaft zu schädigen
und so unseren beitrag unseren
wirtschaftspolitischen beitrag zu
leisten dass dieser krieg irgendwann ein
ende findet in dem wir die russische
wirtschaft bis ins mark treffen werden
und wir sind dabei ist zu tun eine
zwischenfrage aus der afg fraktion ein
särge damen und herren das hat
konsequenzen für mein ministerium und
für den haushalt wir haben in einer
großen geschwindigkeit neue gesetze
schreiben müssen sanktions durchsetzungs
gesetz die sanktion zu kontrollieren
dass energie sicherungs gesetz das in
die beschleunigungsgesetz das kohle
reserve gesetz das bei speicher geist
das gas speichergesetz die verordnung
die heute dazu führt dass reden jetzt
auch pflicht mäßig erfüllt wird die
waffenexporte müssen kontrolliert werden
die hilfsprogramme strukturiert und
verausgabt werden dazu natürlich die
arbeit eine energiewende und an den
strukturellen aufgaben die wir insgesamt
haben dass das im haushalt
nachgezeichnet wird dafür möchte ich
mich ausdrücklich bedanken für die guten
konstruktiven gespräch es ist nicht
selbstverständlich dass das parlament
das sieht ich möchte mich aber auch
bedanken bei der verwaltung jetzt
stellvertretend bei meinem haus letzter
satz man sagt ja immer die verwaltung
die planungsprozesse alles zu langsam
alles zu träge wir zeigen in einer
gemeinschaftlichen anstrengung in diesem
jahr von unternehmen und wirtschaft von
bürgerinnen und bürgern aber auch von
der verwaltung wie leistungsfähig unser
land und unsere demokratie ist der
haushalt sieht mit dass ab vielen dank
bundeswirtschaftsminister robert habeck
am ende noch mit einem blick nach quasi
hinter die kulissen neben dem er sich
auch noch mal an seinem haus gerichtet
hat denn es gibt vieles auf den weg zu
bringen in diesen tag wenn es gelingen
soll das wie er sagt die russische
wirtschaft bis ins mark getroffen werden
soll beispielsweise durch
wirtschaftliche sanktionen und das hat
natürlich auch hierzulande konsequenzen
enrico kölling für die afg fraktion ist
wenn historiker
auf der tribüne wir erleben in
deutschland gegenwärtig ein von der
alten großen koalition angelegten und
von der ampelkoalition
fortgeführten beispielslosen
wirtschaftlichen niedergang in
deutschland erst gestern musste ich am
hauptbahnhof sehen wie ein rentner im
müll umhüllte und sich die pfandflaschen
heraussuchte um seinen lebensunterhalt
zu
erhalten menschen die ein leben lang
gearbeitet haben können von ihrer rente
können von ihren ersparnissen nicht mehr
leben dass es eine schande sie konnte
wie konnte es soweit kommen wie konnte
es so weit kommen dass die bürger dieses
landes ihren strom nicht mehr bezahlen
können und dass eine warme wohnung zum
luxusgut wird es ist ihre bewusst
herbeigeführte zumindest bewusst in kauf
genommene inflation ihre reihen geologie
betriebene vollkommen wirkungslos und
darüber hinaus umwelt zerstörende
energiewende ihre mittelstandsfeindlich
wirtschaftspolitik und nicht zuletzt ihr
historisches taumeln durch die korona
zeit nicht schuld nicht schuld herweck
ist hingegen der ukraine krieg an sich
den sie doch nur dazu nutzen um ihre
fatale wirtschaftspolitik zu
rechtfertigen
sie legen hier einen schuldenhaushalt
einen weiteren schuldenhaushalt vor
diesmal sind es 100 milliarden netto
neuverschuldung leidtragende sind die
mittelständische wirtschaft und die
leistungsträger der gesellschaft nämlich
die arbeitnehmer ganze zehn milliarden
das sind nicht einmal zwei prozent des
gesamthaushaltes fallen in den bereich
wirtschaft
als vormals stellvertretender
verwaltungsratsvorsitzender des bundes
der steuerzahler in mecklenburg
vorpommern weiß ich wie der staat
steuern zum fenster heraus wirft was sie
hier aber machen lässt einen nur noch
ungläubig staunend da finanzieren sie
aus dem wirtschafts haushalts
sozialunternehmen unternehmen ohne
gewinnerzielungsabsicht
unternehmen die nichts aber auch gar
nicht zum wachstum von beschäftigung und
gesellschaftlichen wohlstand beitragen
das können sie von mir aus ja machen
aber nehmen sie doch dann bittet die
mittel aus dem sozial- oder kulturbudget
und dann wiederum streichen sie ein
investitionsprogramm für die
automobilzulieferindustrie zusammen um
fast 200 millionen ein programm das
eigentlich zur zukunftsfähigkeit der von
ihnen geschliffenen deutschen
vorzeigebranche gedacht war blanker hohn
für zigtausende arbeitnehmer und ihre
familien
meine damen und herren
deutschland verarmt vor ihren augen und
sie führen deutschland zielsicher in
eine erbarmungslose
planwirtschaft anstatt gestaltungs
kräfte zu entfesseln und als ehemaliges
fdp-mitglied will ich zumindest an
diesem teil der regierung appelieren
beenden sie diesen ganzen unsinn kehren
sie zurück zur freiheit
chancengleichheit und anstand vielen
dank
der bundestag diskutiert über den
einzelplan 09 eben bundeshaushalt 20 22
das ist der etat für das ministerium für
wirtschaft und klimaschutz 11,33
milliarden euro soll es ausgeben können
und jetzt der wirtschaftspolitische
sprecher der spd fraktion bernd westphal
dazu
zeitgleich zu unserer debatte die wir
hier führen tobt ein erbarmungsloser
schrecklicher krieg in europa der
angriff der feige angriff russlands der
krieg von putin auf die menschen in der
ukraine ist erbärmlich dass wir etwas im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert erleben
müssen ist etwas was wir uns alle kaum
vorstellen können
und deshalb werden wir alles dafür tun
die ukrainerinnen und ukrainer in ihrem
mutigen kampf dagegen zu unterstützen
wir werden alles dafür tun dieses land
in dieser zeit nicht alleine zu lassen
und deshalb ist es richtig das was olaf
scholz ihr am mittwoch in seiner
regierungserklärung gesagt hat alles was
jetzt notwendig ist werden wir für die
ukraine tun meine damen und herren
und natürlich heißt das auch
verantwortung zu übernehmen für die
folgen das sanktionspaket was mit
unseren europäischen partnern und
innerhalb der nato vereinbart worden ist
hat massive auswirkungen auf russland
der wirtschaftsminister hat eben darauf
hingewiesen aber natürlich auch auf die
deutsche wirtschaft und deshalb kann man
sagen dass wir nicht gegen die
wirtschaft sondern wer am sonntag bei
der eröffnung der hannover messe dabei
war konnte das vom präsidenten des
verbandes der deutschen maschinen und
anlagenbauern häuschen hören die
wirtschaft steht hinter dieser
bundesregierung ich würde mir wünschen
dass die opposition in so schwierigen
zeiten das auch tun würde herzlichen
dank für dieses foto
wir befinden uns in einer schwierigen
situation das weiß jeder war dennoch am
messe rundgang am montag in hannover und
schon zum 75 mal findet die stadt in
dieser industrie schaue wo
internationale firmen in deutschland
ihre produkte zeigen wo die
innovationskraft der deutschen
wirtschaft sichtbar wird dort war zu
spüren dass die unternehmen sich auf den
weg machen mitzuhelfen mit ihren
technologien eine klimaneutrale
wirtschaft zu organisieren zu gucken
dass wir mobilität dass wir heizen dass
ihr prozesswärme dass wir die
stromerzeugung dass wir wasserstoff
produzieren das sind innovationen die
dort sichtbar sind und die unternehmen
haben nicht geklagt ersparen über zu
hohe löhne oder dass wir zuviel
arbeitsschutz hätten oder zu viel
mitbestimmung nein ganz im gegenteil
das erste argument was genannt worden
ist wir brauchen fachkräfte in diesem
land und dafür wird dieser
bundeshaushalt sorgen dass wir gerade
die mittel was die ausbildung der
facharbeiter angeht verstärken dass wir
gerade willkommenskultur entwickelt das
menschen mit fachkräften hier nach
deutschland kommen das ist das was
hätten sie sich überzeugen können wenn
sie den rundgang gemacht hätten und
nicht das was sie machen das was die
ideologie der union ist wenn sie über
bürokratieabbau sprechen dann heißt das
schleifen von arbeitnehmerrechten und
lohndrückerei und das werden wir nicht
mitmachen
und deshalb
deshalb ist es zum beispiel richtig wenn
wir inflation über sieben prozent haben
dass sie mit einem großen maßnahmepaket
energiepreise dementsprechend entlasten
aber auch mit dem mindestlohngesetz
dafür sorgen dass wir lohnerhöhung von
teilweise 30 prozent im
niedriglohnsektor haben sechs millionen
menschen werden in diesem land davon
profitieren und deshalb ist das richtig
dass wir dieses gesetz auf den weg
bringen um die kaufkraft zu erhöhen das
steuert dagegen das schafft stabilität
in unserer wirtschaft
das was der haushalt auch macht und die
gesetze mit oster paket und das was noch
zu erwarten ist aus dem
wirtschaftsministerium zeigt ja das ist
ja spaß macht in einer bundesregierung
mit ab mitzuarbeiten und ich habe ja
acht jahre
energiepolitik mit verantwortet für
meine fraktion dass es spaß macht jetzt
genau diese transformation zu gestalten
erneuerbare energien auszubauen
kommunen und länder zu stärken im
genehmigungsverfahren schneller zu
werden eine aufbruch situation zu
erzeugen genau das ist der investive
teil denen diese bundesregierung jetzt
als signal sendet und genau das ist
etwas was unser land und unsere
wirtschaft zukunftsfähig macht und nicht
zaudern und bremsen das ist gott sei
dank jetzt vorbei die ampel ist
innovativer in dieser regierung
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
die wirtschaft mit diesen
herausforderungen ist gestärkt die
rahmenbedingungen die wir als
bundesregierung setzen sind genau diese
innovationstreiber wir sind investitions
und innovation unterstützer und förderer
das zeigt der bundeshaushalt zum
beispiel mit einem sehr erfolgreichen
instrument der zukunft investitionen für
den mittelstand das zimmer creme wird
noch einmal mit mitteln erhöht es ist
ein programm was abgefragt wird was in
den unternehmen auch anerkannt ist die
mittel werden abgerufen und fördern
genau diese innovationskraft die wir
brauchen auch übrigens in einem
internationalen wettbewerb wir merken
dass dass wir auch international auf den
märkten mit diesen produkten erfolgreich
sind gleichzeitig fordern wir die
industrielle gemeinschaftsforschung
auch das sind zeichen wo man sieht wie
die innovation durch bundeshaushalts
mitteln unterstützt werden und deshalb
ist das ein gutes haushalt den mann
zustimmen kann er fördert die wende zur
sozial ökologischen wirtschaft und
deshalb seit 1863 spd schafft soziale
verantwortung vielen dar
sagt der wirtschaftspolitische sprecher
der spd-bundestagsfraktion
bernd westphal in dieser debatte über
den etat des
bundeswirtschaftsministers robert habeck
alexander ullrich ist der nächste redner
kommt aus der linksfraktion ist sowohl
sprecher für europäische sozial und
wirtschaftspolitik als auch für
industriepolitik
die frage diese auch nicht beantwortet
haben wen meinen sie denn alles mit wir
denn für viele menschen in diesem land
trifft das zwar zu bis zu 40 prozent der
haushalte kommen nicht mehr durch den
monat viele schon vor des krieges und
corona aber für viele andere stellen wir
fest dass reichtum sich anhäuft die zahl
der millionäre milliardäre steigt an die
ölkonzerne machen geschäfte ohne ende
werden auch von ihm dabei unterstützt
und das zeigt wir haben in dieser krise
geht die soziale ungleichheit weiter
auseinander es stimmt nicht dass wir
alle ärmer werden ein teil der
gesellschaft wird ärmer und das auch
politisch von ihnen gewollt
und wenn sie von wir reden dann können
sie auch nicht meinen wenn der heute
show verpasst mal zu erklären warum zum
beispiel die rentnerinnen der rentner an
der studierende die 300 euro energie
geld nicht bekommt aber sie als
vizekanzler bekommen die 300 euro finden
sie dass respektvoll diesen wahlkampf
und bei der regierungsbildung gerissen
hat nein das respektlos hat sich das
kabinett bedient und rentabel und
wenn wir hier auch darüber reden
vorredner war ja für soziale seit 1847
für sozialen austausch steht die spd der
ministerpräsident von niedersachsen hat
jetzt in einem bild am sonntag in der
jugend sagt er ist auch dafür dass bei
den rentnerinnen und rentner nachgelegt
wird leider wird man von der spd
bundestagsfraktion nicht ob sie das
unterstützt also an die bürgerinnen
bürger auch in niedersachsen der
ministerpräsident macht wahlkampf und
spätestens mit dem wahltermin ist auch
diese aussage wieder fehl am platze sie
machen mal wieder etwas sie wollen die
rentnerin rentner im stich lassen dass
die wahrheit und diese woche hat das
auch nochmals gezeigt
und herr das minister habe gestern hat
der kanzler angesprochen er will eine
konzertierte aktion zwischen
arbeitgebern und gewerkschaften wie man
dieser installation umgeht ich hätte mir
gewünscht dass sie als
wirtschaftsminister hier mal ein paar
hinweise geben wohin die konzertierte
aktion gehen soll sollen die leute
nochmals auf lohnerhöhungen verzichten
was der wirtschaft so schwer geht soll
es ein aus walschleben des staates wir
sagen klipp und klar mit den
gewerkschaften das was jetzt gemacht
haben ist halb gare wir brauchen
vielmehr in der entlassung von der
politik damit auch die menschen wirklich
auch da nicht im stich gelassen werden
in diesen krisen corona und ukraine
vielen dank
und es folgt die fdp fraktion mit ihren
redner weihnachten
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
glaube olaf scholz hat gestern gesagt zu
friedrich merz der leider gegangen ist
er würde durch die rede tänzeln ersparen
sie haben auch ziemlich viel getänzelt
also wenn die große kompetenz der union
darin besteht und sie jetzt zu empfehlen
wie der in die atomwirtschaft
einzusteigen muss ich sagen wo haben sie
eigentlich ihren marktwirtschaftlichen
kompass sie wissen doch ganz genau dass
keine bank ein atomkraftwerk in
deutschland finanzieren wird und sie
wissen ganz genau dass keine
versicherung ein atomkraftwerk
versichert würde und in dem zusammenhang
kann ich sagen ich empfehle dann die
endlagersuche land ersparen
[Applaus]
die aussage zum gasspeicher dann gucken
sie doch bitte in die täglichen
informationen der bundesnetzagentur wie
das einspeichern in unsere da speicher
funktioniert und in welchem tempo sie
stattfinden dann könnten sie solche
aussagen die sie hier getroffen haben
eigentlich nicht voranbringen also das
kann meiner meinung nach nicht sagen
natürlich müssen wir der deutschen
wirtschaft danken sie akzeptiert das
primat der politik aber meine damen und
herren die wirtschaft ist natürlich auch
in großer sorge
und deswegen begrüßen wir als fdp
natürlich die verstärkten anstrengungen
gerade bei allen sie und herr minister
es ist natürlich traurig dass sie
verkündet haben also liebe ich will
jetzt nicht unbedingt sagen
vorfeldorganisationen der grünen aber
bnd und nabe und so weiter und so fort